[Laughter]
okay um i think it's a good day for
2020 the sun is out again
this guy doesn't look like mars as far
as i can see air is
so so but um meteoroid didn't hit yet
and
we are still waiting for the big one in
the bay area what's your work ethic like
what do you do
on a usual day
there are no usual days so in some sense
every day is
its own and uh every day has its own
demands and so on and
i do block out times and do plan things
ahead but
for the most part i get up i have
breakfast
i work i spend time with the family in
between
and uh at some point uh i
uh maybe read a few pages in a book or
watch a movie with the family and go to
bed do you tend to work in solid blocks
uninterrupted because you need that for
focus
it depends on the type of work so when i
uh write code
i need long solitary times alone if i
want to
write a book i need to have a solid
leaks
weeks for myself so i don't write a book
at this point um
maybe i figure out how to do this anyway
while being locked up with the family
and when i do conceptual work and so on
i can do this in short intervals and
sometimes i do something else interrupt
it
because i realized i need to write
something down
we're going to get into some fairly deep
questions right off the bat
so what is your definition of truth
do you take a correspondence theory of
truth for example
i think that truth has is defined
in a mathematical paradigm which means
it's
defined visit a language and it's a
certain
value that you set on
variables that have the property that
they can be
true or false or have a truth value that
varies in degrees
and in some sense truth is a predicate
that you can calculate
in this context and uh you can
translate this into the languages that
our mind is typically using which are
models and in these models we can have
some kind of truth definition which
means that the
model depending on the type of model
that you have
can conform to any of your mathematical
tools definitions so it can be
something that is can be reduced to a
set of axioms for instance
and this means that it can be in some
sense compressed to the
set of axioms or expanded from the set
of axioms into
a certain state of that descriptive
system
and it's difficult to apply truth to
an outside world so i don't believe in
reference theory of truth these
references can only exist between
different models
on the other hand we normally never talk
about the outside world because it's
this weird quantum graph that
is not accessible to us and that we
take to be the system that generates
patterns on our retina
and and on our systemic interface to the
universe
and
all these patterns rate models and
different
the primary one is an integrated model
of the entire universe of interception
is inspect
or the perception of external things
plus proprioception
right so we in some sense have um
res extensor and the rest cognitions to
speak with descartes and res extensor is
not the universe itself
it's our model of the universe it's the
idea that everything that we perceive
corresponds to a region in the same
three-dimensional space that is
dynamically changing
as a temporal extension as well and uh
rescogins is everything else our ideas
that we have about that the anticipation
that we have hypotheses that we have
memories
that we have intentions that we have and
so on
and these two interact but there are
several types of models that
co-exist in our own mind and when we uh
refer to something in the world we refer
to something in the
integrated model of the universe that we
have that is changing
and it's it's not static it's it's not
reality
for instance my model of the universe at
some level contains colors and sounds
and there are no colors and sounds in
the physical universe
right the physical universe does not
offer them but
uh colors and sounds are functions that
our brain computes to interpret certain
types of patterns in the universe
so you're saying when we talk sorry so
you're suggesting that the underlying
reality is physical and
it's a quantum graph what do you mean by
it's a quantum graph
uh what i mean is that there is an
outside pattern generator and the
physics is exploring the idea that this
pattern generator can be explained by
a causally closed set of rules right
somewhere out there there is a system
that
generates us and that generates our
experiences
and the big insight of computation is
that a
computational system is the necessary
and sufficient means to produce
arbitrary patterns
and we don't have alternatives to
computational descriptions
that are able to do that so
it turns out that computation is a way
to frame language
and if we want to have languages that
describe systems that can produce
patterns and are self-consistent and can
reduce the first principles these are
computational systems
and then when i say it's a quantum graph
basically a graphical representation one
that
disassembles a system into nodes that
can hold for instance state
and links between them that translate
this state between the nodes
this is a very general computational
description and so
in some sense we can describe everything
especially extended things that play out
in a space as a
graph a space is basically a
if you talk about something like a
geometric space
as a very very regular graph that
happens if you zoom out far enough
so there's basically a graph with so
many nodes and so many links
between them and so regular ways of
translating information in them that you
can
describe the function of the entire
thing in the limit
by operators that give rise to geometry
all languages can be summarized in
mathematics and then there's a subset
that is computation
and this is the one that corresponds to
our world is that what you're suggesting
so uh what i would say is that a way out
look
of looking at what mathematics is it's
the domain of all languages
and mathematicians are starting out with
the simplest languages
and exploring them and these are the
formal languages those where
you already know all the properties or
you
define them in such a way that you have
a good chance to explore most of the
properties
step by step and especially you can
define them in such a way that you can
make proofs in them and the reason why
we explore mathematics are
[Music]
by default there's one that we want to
understand uh the things that we only
intuitively understand
for instance geometry right we have an
intuitive understanding of geometry and
it's because our brain makes
geometric models of the world that we
are embedded in
and so we want to have a way to talk
about these models in a way that makes
them explicit
and uh allows us to debug them and
allows us to
express them as formal systems to teach
them to check up
on whether our minds did the geometry
right and so on right
and to have all these uh models of
models these formal descriptions of
geometry
that's one reason why we need
mathematics and it's one of the reasons
why
our present mathematical tradition
started it's
uh it started very often as geometrical
descriptions
and the algebraic descriptions that we
have those in terms of formulas and so
on are often
a specification for the geometry and
in some sense we teach mathematics of
the wrong way around
in school we teach kids algebra first
as an extension of counting or
generalization of counting
and then you have something like x uh
y equals say x square
and this is an algebraic description
right and then we learn how to graph
these functions and then we
uh notice oh my god this uh graph of
this function looks a lot like a
parabola what a coincidence
and now we see if we can use this
algebraic description to describe the
parabola
but uh i think that uh the invention was
the other way around
like the world is full of parabolas
whenever you throw stuff you see a
parabola
and then you ask yourself uh what's
going on here how can i systematize that
and then you realize
okay i can make a specification that
makes this
thing computable because i can compute
the algorithmic description there's an
algorithm for
computing y equals x square
right and this allows me to compute the
trajectory of an object that i throw
this is one of the ways that we
discovered mathematics
the other one is uh that all languages
that we are using so
logic uh is a
mathematical principle and it's uh in
some sense a subset of the natural
languages that we use
but we can extend it in such a way that
it's encompassing
the natural languages in a way and
there was always a big hope that we
could make logic so general
that we can make natural languages so
precise that they become
the same thing that these languages in
which we refer
to facts can uh express things that we
can prove
in a formal strict sense in a way that
we can build machines that can
perform uh language and that can make
statements
that are true or false and so on we look
at the world and we see some patterns
and we try to model those patterns in
mathematics as a great way of modeling
those
patterns is that essentially what you're
saying or is it something else
so mathematics allows us to build
arbitrary languages not just natural
language but it also allows us to build
languages that
for instance start out with only with
bits or that starts out with
bit vectors and you could say that for
instance a major learning system
is using a language that as an input as
a bit vector for instance the bit vector
that comes in
from a camera sensor and then it maps
this to other bit vectors and just by
finding or
order in the patterns it it's able to
gradually make some sense of these
patterns it's
able to relate them and it's for
instance it's able to discover
that if you feed it enough bit vectors
all these bit vectors uh refer to
objects in the three-dimensional space
because that's the best compression that
you find over them it's the best way
to make sense of these patterns to build
a model of these patterns that is most
predictive
of their structure and mathematics
allows us
to construct and understand the
languages in which that takes place
and you alluded to another thing that is
uh
the difference between computation and
mathematics the
classical definition of mathematics that
we use in our tradition is mostly time
and stateless it's basically everything
is taking place
in a single state so if you want to
express a temporal sequence in
mathematics
you usually use an index and this index
can be
discrete or continuous and you just
basically define something like a loop
only it's not like a loop in a
programming language which goes
through this literally step by step to
compute the sequence
you have so instance an integral
operator and this integral operator
states
that god makes a loop in one moment and
this loop can
integrate over infinitely many elements
because god can do that right it's an
idealized version of what mathematics
can do and it turns out that there are
no gods that have the power to
take infinity melee elements and really
integrate them
what we can do is we can take a very
very large number of elements that to us
is almost indistinguishable from
infinitely many elements and then we can
integrate them in a pretty were pretty
long time span of however long it takes
but not
over an infinite amount of time but if
we had really infinitely many elements
that you would try to
throw together to integrate to put into
one function
and execute that function over these
elements this is not possible
in anything that is implemented in the
physical universe and it's also not
possible for anything that is
implemented in mathematics itself
without leading into contradictions so
in some sense what google discovered
i think is that mathematics this
infinities that actually uses these
infinities to compute things is leading
into contradictions
and the thing that doesn't do that that
only uses states
that we can in some sense count up and
uh actually execute on this is
computation the subset of mathematics
that can be constructed
constructive mathematics and
i would say that constructive
mathematics is not
a subset of mathematics unless you say
that mathematics also encompasses those
things that don't work
right you could say mathematics is all
languages also those languages that are
utter nonsense because they are
contradictory
um that that is one way of looking at it
but the part of mathematics that works
is computation the part of mathematics
that can be implemented
and i think for something to be real it
needs to be implemented
something that is not implementable
something that cannot be realized as a
system that is executable by anything
in mathematics or in physics
is not real right so constructive
mathematics is the part of mathematics
that has a chance
of being real right now
when you say real do you mind defining i
know you just subtly defined it do you
mind explicitly defining what
real is because the way that i'm
thinking about this is
you just mentioned there's classical
mathematics let's just call it classical
mathematics
and it leads to contradictions like
girdle mentioned and one way of
interpreting that is there are limits to
our knowledge there are limits to
mathematics another way is that this is
the wrong mathematics this is not what
is describing our universe what's real
is something else so girdle you actually
said that this is a blind alley don't go
down that alley rather than
this is the alley and here's our
limitations you're like no no no
here's constructive mathematics and
you're saying that this is real okay
help me understand what you mean when
you say real
uh just as a small tangent i think it's
unfair to goodell to
pretend that this is what he thought he
said
good actually believed in in this god of
mathematics that came to these
infinities
and it was a big shock to him when he
came up with this proof and
uh so in some sense he
discovered something about the
mathematics that he believed in that
seemed to be real to him
that he could not really get square
and it's also a thing that a lot of
mathematicians and physicists struggle
for instance i think it's part of
what motivates roger penrose when he
uh rejects the idea that computers can
be conscious because he thinks
that human minds can do non-computable
mathematics
in the same way as good to him goodell
has proven that computers cannot do all
of mathematics but
human minds can for instance there uh
penrose has discovered these penrose
tilings these are uh
there are tidings which uh have an
infinite variation right there are
infinities
how can you claim that there are no
infinities but you can
you're only looking at a function i
think that basically
has an open-ended result it's similar to
the function that computes pi pi is not
just a value
pi is a function or a set of functions
that give you for instance if you
translate this into the decimal system
digits
it's an infinite sequence of digits and
you can get as many digits as you can
afford
but you can never have a function that
relies on having known the last digit of
pi
where there is nothing where you feed in
pi and you get a result
you can only feed in a number of digits
of pi and you get a partial result
and uh this result has the property that
for
it converges because the digits that you
get
denotes smaller and smaller fractions of
pi and so the
results tend to converge to something
but ultimately you don't know the end of
it
and uh so we have to be fair to girdle
to
uh he he did not believe in computation
as a solution he's he was uh
strongly buried to this pre-constructive
mathematics and non-constructive
mathematics and
he basically thought that mathematics is
somehow
it has a big problem in itself and it
doesn't it was just a problem of the
formatization that mathematicians have
been
using for a long time okay so uh let's
get back to your original question
yeah well we just have it up again
what is real also we're talking about
this pi
does the number pi exist oh no
like this sounds a bit odd but to some
people it's like well the pythagorean
theorem was discovered it wasn't
invented that
the pythagorean theorem for example is
true regardless of if humans are around
okay
then we can say does one exist did we
discover the number one or did it exist
and then we can similarly ask does pi
exist
so what do you think does pi exist what
does it mean to exist
i think that pi is being constructed and
there
are is a procedure for this construction
that we have discovered
and pi is as real as the mandelbrot
fractal
there is real in pretty much the same
sense right there is this
pattern that is self-contained
it is uh there whether you are looking
at it or not and it's a pattern
that cannot physically exist at least
not at
an infinite resolution because it's a
pattern that is defined with a procedure
that
gives you more resolution the deeper you
get into it
and you will never know the last details
of the mandelbrot fractal and the same
way you will never know
the last details of pi right but there's
a difference between
whether or not we can know it whether or
not it's computable and whether or not
it exists
i think that pi in the sense that you
say it's
defined with the last details does not
exist but
because it cannot be implemented there
can be no
system built into the universe that
is uh expressing the last digits of pi
so the last digits of pi do not exist
in the sense that they are real that
they are there somehow that they are out
there
and influence anything that they have a
causal influence on something else
and for something to exist it uh i think
it is implemented
in such a way that it has a causal
influence on other things
and uh can be uh consistently described
with a model that is describing that
causal influence
and so do the integers exist
not all of them so and right there's a
large number n yeah so
i would say that the integers are a
model they're a way of
talking about things that are real
but it's pointless to say that this
model exists
because well it's a structure that is
being constructed the
implementation of the structure in your
own mind is being constructed the
realization of piano's arithmetic
in a computational system exists in a
way it's implemented to such a degree
that
for a certain amount of time that system
can be stable enough to allow us to
perform computations
with a certain accuracy and at some
point these computers are going to fall
apart
what i would say exists is
one way of looking at this and it's
basically a thesis that i don't know how
to prove is that there is a causally
closed lowest layer that exists
and this is basically the mechanics of
the universe some kind of automaton that
produces everything that happens
and there seems to be something right
something seems to be real
and um why is there something rather
than laughing i don't know why that is
in some sense it's the most obscene
thing that something exists rather than
nothing it's tremendous
it's much more confusing than everything
else i'm aware of
and the easiest explanation for that is
that existence is the default
so perhaps everything that can exist
which means implemented without
contradictions
exist somehow and so you have the
superposition of all these computational
operators and some of these
regions of the resulting fractal
contains s
right so i'm sure you've heard of the
multiverse this sounds similar to the
multiverse that anything that can't
happen
happens it exists in some way shape or
form
we had a power outage i'm sorry and the
and the worst thing the oh
the audio is gone okay okay that's okay
i hope that you're recording on your
site yes
yeah yeah i am i'm thoroughly recording
good
okay yeah okay he is conspiring against
us
yeah that's all right it doesn't want
the secrets revealed
okay okay so so yosha
i was asking what's the difference
between what you just mentioned
and the multiverse idea which is
something akin to
whatever can exist whatever is possible
exists
in some way shape or form in some other
universe i think that the
uh multiverse in the everett villagram
version this idea that there is
basically at every decision of
the quantum collapse
the collapse of the wave function the
universe splits into copies of itself
is a slightly different conception it's
basically a mathematical
paradigm that describes that the
universe is
branching in ways that parts
of the description of the universe no
longer causally influence the other
parts of the description of the universe
imagine that you are describing the
world as
something like a cellular automaton and
uh
in the cellular automaton you have
particles interaction
interactions which might be like gliders
in the game of life like these
regular patterns that might influence
each other and change state and
move through the topology of a space
that you define
in a certain way and uh it this thing is
defined in such a way that
the computation of the entire thing is
very inefficient because
it at every step the thing splits up
into many many sub topologies in which
you have copies of these sliders or
variants of these sliders
moving about in different ways but only
a subset of the gliders is going to
influence the others so from the
perspective of the future of this
of any kind of system the only things
that are real to you are those that can
causely influence you
and if something moves away from you in
a way that it can no longer
causally influence you and because it's
no longer occupying the same space in a
way
but we basically have a space with
dimensionality that increases and
increases and increases
and this might look like it's extremely
wasteful
but that's only from the perspective of
somebody who is outside of the system
and cares about one of the timelines
of the system and we only exist visit
one of those trajectories inside
and for us we would only experience
a smaller and smaller fraction of the
resulting computation
at every moment and or in the future as
a in potentia
and this is in some sense was this
multiverse idea describes it's a
particular mathematical formalism
it's not exactly the same as uh the one
the thing that i just described because
that is independent of the idea of such
a multiverse
so uh what what i described is a way to
look at the universe as something like
in evolving fractals you have a
generator function that produces
all the possible generator function by
just enumerating them and just
executing them in parallel and as a
result you get
a time space and matter and structure
matter is basically the structure that
is evolving in this phase and is
propelled along it and space
is a set of locations that you can
discern that can contain information
that is discernible
and the ways that the information can
travel between these locations
and uh yeah so you're saying that
we can produce some subsets that are
causally closed and then there are
others that don't influence us at all
and to us whoever lives within this
causally closed place so you know what i
mean they
are constantly looping back to us so
you send a signal into the universe this
uni signal is going to influence certain
things
and as a result you you get feedback
from this right you push a certain thing
and
you see the results of what you pushed
because photons are bounced off that
thing that you are pushing
and there is a limit to that that is uh
the
visible universe right the uh if
something goes uh
beyond the region from which light can
reach us it's
it no longer has a causal influence to
us and the multiverse theory is that
uh the there is not just this boundary
uh in a very very large distance
but there is a boundary next to us where
we do things that
lead to information flowing away from us
and not coming back to us
still there is a conservation of
information this conservation of
information is that
we can always basically in some sense
figure out what we did
because all the influences that matter
get back to us
and of course uh the there is a little
bit of a tautology in there
if we are producing things in the
universe with our actions that in some
sense would generate new information
that goes away from us and doesn't come
back we would never know about it
and in some sense the multiverse is an
inevitable description
of such a universe that where the
collapse of the wave function can happen
in multiple ways where are the other
ways
happening where are they going why is it
that we only experience this particular
collapse of the wave function and the
multiverse theory is a possible answer
to that
and there are other possible answers to
that um one could be that
for instance the collapse of the wave
function is deterministic
in in this in a certain sense and that
is
means that it's influenced by things
that are non-local
and that we cannot pinpoint do you
believe that the universe is ultimately
deterministic
i don't really have beliefs about that i
i think that the
conservation of information seems to
imply that the universe is deterministic
it also depends on what you see as
determinism or in determinism a
deterministic function is one that gives
the same result every time
so the universe being deterministic
means we can't find a function
that describes everything using the same
function
and if it's an independent deterministic
one you get a different result
every time as a transition between
adjacent states of a system
and you can express this by taking
a deterministic function and adding some
of infinitely long string of random
numbers or a string of random numbers
that is longer than
you can observe and in this case you
will have an irregularity
that is not predictable and so
you can always find in some sense a
deterministic model to describe a system
unless you can completely see how it's
made
up and this problem is that we cannot
understand the makeup of an
indeterministic system you cannot open a
box and see
a true random number generator because a
true random
number generator cannot be constructed
and you can construct a function that
gives you the digits of pi
but you cannot construct a function that
gives you a an
infinite number of random numbers
what do you think is giving rise to the
initial conditions you mentioned that
maybe existence is the default
what gives rise to that and what gives
you the
rules maybe there are no initial
conditions
so uh the big bang is not in some sense
initial condition
of the universe itself its initial
condition from the perspective of an
observer
when we uh look at the universe we
notice that
while there is um
there's it's not symmetrical right there
isn't a symmetry in the universe
but it's reversible in the sense that
every state seems to have exactly one
preceding state
and this means that there are parts
of the in the universe that remember
other parts of the universe
if you are for instance taking a a
billiard ball and you send it through
the universe
then there is a reversibility in this
because you could if you would trace uh
all the interactions that the billiard
ball enters uh
directly and do this in the inverse you
could basically restore the state that
existed before the billiard ball entered
it
but you also see this fundamental
asymmetry and this is the stuff behind
the billiard ball remembers the billiard
ball passing
and the stuff before the billiard ball
doesn't yet know that it comes it
doesn't remember that the billiard ball
will
soon cross through this area and break
some havoc
and change things right and this means
that there is this
entropic arrow in the universe and this
describes in
in one direction that
in which way information gets dispersed
to the universe in which way locations
begin remembering uh the state of other
locations
in which way information gets smeared
around between locations
and there is an ideal state that this
hasn't happened yet where all the
locations uh
have information that self-contained
that is not correlated with other
information
in other locations and this is the big
bank state
and if you go past the big bank state in
the opposite direction so
if you would move to the time before the
big bank state the entropic arrow points
away from the big bang so basically
uh all the directions that point away
from the big bang
in time are future of the big bang
because they're all ones that remember a
trajectory that ends in this ideal
original state where the information is
perfectly
correlated with location but this
doesn't mean that the big bank state has
ever existed
it's just a mathematical description of
a singularity in
our entropic era of time
i'm not clear what you mean by that
there's a memory of the
of the state but either way when you say
that there's the big bang and then
there's an entropic arrow
there's a huge mystery a mystery in
physics about the arrow of time
like what is time and why does it move
forward is it static like you mentioned
if we conceptualize the world in
classical non-constructivist mathematics
then there's no
room for time what is time in your model
it's time fundamental um i think that if
you
want to have an observer you need to
have a system that is
multi-stable and it it's
moving between these states right it
needs to be able to be influenced by the
environment
and as a result form some kind of memory
the memory means that
as a result of an observation at the
system-made
environment it's changing its internal
state in a particular
deterministic way and
the way that we've described our
universe we noticed that
we can describe our universe in terms of
states of which some
explain this current state by being its
past
you could also say imagine you enumerate
all the possible universe states and
some of these states will look like
they contain the memory of past states
because they are
can be the result of a state transition
where you are
using a permutation on previous bits
basically the laws of physics
and you get to the next state and as if
you go backwards
you get a timeline and all the possible
timelines
in the space of uh the enumeration of
universe states
these are all the possible temporally
extended universes
from the perspective of an observer uh
time is
uh in some sense the rate of change in
the environment
as uh observed by the observer which
means it's relative to the rate of
change in the observer
so from observer perspective time is
intrinsically relativistic
from uh the perspective of outside of
the system which we cannot take
time would be state transition so there
is a way in which you
would enumerate the states by uh
defining a function
that orders them
okay you just mentioned from the
perspective of of an observer outside
the system
now in general relativity an observer is
what follows the time-like
curve okay so you're in the cone can't
be spaced like can't be null
now if you ask what's what what the heck
is the experience of a photon
we can't do that because an observer is
defined as what's in the time-like
cone the thing is the photon is not
multi-stable the photon does not change
state
right that's why the photon is not able
to observe
the photon can be absorbed and
re-emitted with different properties but
by itself the photon doesn't change
and uh only a system that is able to
change state can observe
and so whenever you have a particle
system like you and me right like a
single one a single one though what
about a single particle
uh it depends what kind of particle but
uh so
in some sense you can describe every uh
particle system
as some kind of a compound particle but
it's basically depends on whether you
can uh change a property
of of that particle without that
particle
uh changing its identity so to speak
right so uh as as soon as this model of
the particle that
no longer applies you use a different
description
you used to write for edge i don't know
if you still do but in the
last question you wrote what is the
optimal algorithm for finding truth
i'm curious to know what is the optimal
algorithm
i don't know that so uh in some sense
the
this is a question for people that work
in artificial intelligence
that is when you exist in
circumstances that are learnable you try
to learn about these circumstances you
make a model of them
what's the best algorithm that you can
employ to
discover a model of what state you're in
and you can show that for the general
case that's not possible not every
system is learnable
but it seems that the set of universes
that can contain
us has certain limitations right not
every possible universe can contain us
the universe that can contain us is must
be essentially a controllable universe
from our perspective it seems that in
some sense
atoms control elementary particles and
molecules control atoms
and cells control molecules and
organisms
control cells and societies control
organisms and so on right so we look at
the hierarchy of control
it's a one way of looking at the
complexity that we're seeing
and a system that is being controlled
that has has some kind of control
structure
implies that the controller implements a
model of that what is controlling
otherwise it couldn't control it
right if you can implement a model of
something it means that the model is
discoverable
which means that the system is learnable
a controllable universe is a learnable
universe
the non-controlled parts of the universe
will look random to us
they're not controllable but what we can
see is largely controllable right there
are some zero point fluctuations of the
universe
that we cannot control we don't know uh
where they come from we don't know how
to influence them
and uh the particles that we are looking
at are those
parts of the fluctuation that are
regular enough to be described in some
kind of good control model
it's tempting to think of the universe
like
something like say the surface of an
ocean that is in constant fluctuation
and these fluctuations look uh random to
something that is swimming on that
surface
and uh but on the surface there are also
regular patterns
for some things like water vortices and
these water vertices need to have
particular properties to be stable and
when they have these properties they're
almost indestructible
basically there are is a certain number
of molecules that need to be
involved in a certain way as a certain
speed and then suddenly you get a vortex
that is so stable that it can only be
broken up by hitting other vortices that
have
compatible or uh properties that are in
some relationship to that
right and this is roughly i think a
model of the particle dynamics that
you're looking at
there are some patterns in in the
overall dynamics
that are so stable that they can be
described by control models and can be
exploited
by higher level control structures so
they give rise to complexity
and the ones that can't we just don't
observe them or we observe them
as random or we observe them as noise
yes
they're not predictable right they in
some sense the meaning of information
is its relationship to change in other
information
so if you see a blip on your retina the
relationship of that blip
to other blips of red on your retina is
the meaning that this
blip has right this meaning that you
discover is a function
that describes the relationship of blips
on your retina to each other to these
different changes as
uh for instance people in a room that is
lit and that the sunshine's on and these
people
walk around they exchange ideas and the
room is three-dimensional and so on and
so on right this is the function that
your brain discovers
to describe all the blips on your retina
there are other blips on your retina
that do not fit into this function and
these blips are noise
and there's a lot of noise on our retina
and in some sense this is also how we
interpret the universe everything where
we discover a relationship to the other
things
this is what we can model and the rest
is noise
and the amazing thing is that physics is
clarifying the universe to such a high
degree and there's so little noise left
do you think that ultimately there will
be no noise left that will be able to
characterize everything
i think that we will always be able to
construct a function that
uh behaves as if there was no noise that
basically explains everything
but it doesn't mean that this function
is necessarily predictive it doesn't
need to be the correct function
and it's not the only function that can
explain it it's like
imagine you live in a computer program
like minecraft
and uh you observe all the patterns
around you you can always construct a
computer program that will work like
minecraft and will explain all the
patterns around you
even the random patterns right you can
always come up with some pseudo-random
number generator that produces this
but uh you will not necessarily be able
to discover the truth of the matter
except um if the world that you live in
is so simple
that it suggests itself that there is
only one simple function
or a class of simple function that can
be mapped on to each other with a simple
transformation that gives the same
result every time
right so imagine that you discover yet
you live in a mandelbrot fractal
the mental board factor is like two
lines of code and
you can express these lines of code in
many many different ways so
many ways of expressing the same
function the same sequence
but there are mappings between all of
those and uh
so if you discover the mandelbrot
fractal you can basically say this is
the simplest function that explains it
this is the reality that you're looking
at this
a simple sequential definition of
how to calculate these pixels on that
plane and it's conceivable that we would
find such a function for our universe
but if the universe is very complicated
we can still find a very complicated
function in some sense
the quest of physics is to find the
shortest function and the current
function that we have that explains most
stuff not everything but most is the
standard model it's like half a page of
quote
and it's it's already very short but
physicists keep hoping for something
that is much shorter because
other page of code is still very
complicated and people ask themselves
that how
does all this complexity come from do
you think that ultimately the
code is short or do you think that like
feynman was quoted saying that it might
even be an onion where
you just keep unveiling the layers and
it's more and more complex
less and less complex and it doesn't
follow necessarily a pattern maybe
there's not even a center
do you believe there's a center and you
believe that center is simple
it's a weird metaphors it's mostly ways
that we think about the world that we
should deconstruct before we trust them
right what does it mean that for
something to be a center
it's inside of something and the onion
is outside and it's spatially aligned
so what this describes is probably a
hierarchy of models
and the question is does every
subsequent layer of modeling that we
discover becomes simpler and simpler
imagine you take a microscope
and you look at a cell and you zoom in
and
every at every level of resolution where
you discover a new structure
the question is does the structure
become more simple or more complex
right and does the model converge to
something ultimately
yeah and i think that
it's very likely that it does converge
to something from what i understand
but i cannot make such a proof at this
point i think that it uh
must converge to something because there
are no infinities things needs to be
constructed
there is also this weird properties that
for instance if you look at the particle
generations
they are integer fractions that describe
uh how they are
uh how they differ in their properties
right so uh
it could be that there are uh smallest
building blocks of information
that uh make up the particles that
you're looking at there is no infinite
division between them
and so it could be that the the course
of the closest lowest layer
is somewhere uh inside it's something
that we can still construct
is it cool if we get into the nitty
gritty i have some questions about your
powerpoint slides
yes just one uh one more thing i didn't
answer the question for uh for the
optimal algorithm to discover yes great
let's get back to that
right so let's let's get back to that
sorry i went on to attention there but i
thought it was necessary
so uh in some sense when you look at
artificial intelligence systems
uh there was a succession of ideas and
in classical ai
uh people have been looking at problems
like playing chess
and constructing algorithms to solve
that problem mostly by hand
and when they looked at new problems
they had to construct a new algorithm
and then we had this idea of finding
more general algorithms that can
work over a very large class of problems
general problem solvers and there is
difficulty that
if you have a description that is so
general that it works on many
uh problems then the description is
typically
uh so general that uh it's too long for
a concrete problem
it basically takes too long to explore
the space using this general description
you get a
explosion of complexity there are too
many possibilities that you would have
to look into if you enumerate them all
with your general description so uh you
end up needing
a targeted exploration of the space of
possibilities
and this is what the current wave of ai
is doing it's looking for algorithms
that discover solutions for problems so
instead of implementing a solution for
chess
we give the system a specification for
chess and then we let it explore the
solution space
right it's discovering uh an algorithm
to play chess
using an algorithm that we give it so we
construct a learning algorithm
and the next stage could be that we just
describe
an algorithm that discovers a learning
algorithm for this
this is meta learning so we don't build
a system that learns
people decision that learns how to learn
a given thing
right and then a question is is this the
generally best solution already
or if not maybe we need to get one step
above and we need to discover a general
theory of search
a general mathematical theory says how
to optimally search given certain
boundary conditions
the way that i'm conceptualizing what
you said is in the first wave of
artificial intelligence it's almost like
if then statements extremely structured
here's how to play chess i'm going to
implement the rules myself then the
second wave is look at
a slew of chess and learn the rules and
learn how to play well
then you're saying that okay well that's
great it's like watson watson's
wonderful at one task
but then when you want to generalize
watson can you also move your arms okay
well that require and also be
regular watson that's a bit difficult
watson can you move your arms
and talk to people it requires too much
time
because your your function is too
general but yet our brains do it
are you saying something like that or am
i completely wrong almost almost
starting with watson it's a family of
things basically it's a brand that ibm
has been using to
label its ai efforts or part of its ai
efforts after
uh the jeopardy thing became famous so
it's watson is not one thing
it's many things and it's
slightly different from uh alphago
because alphago is an algorithm that is
specified in a particular paper and
deepmind is not renaming everything that
it does into alphago because alphago got
famous
right it's uh it has alpha zero and
there's a number of other things that
algorithms that are somewhat related
and uh eventually when you talk about
the algorithms you can also use the
technical name you could look at
for instance deep q learning and uh deep
q learning is a particular
small class of algorithms that can solve
certain problems very well and
others not very well at the moment the
most interesting class of algorithms a
lot of people are talking about
one of the most interesting ones is
transformers which
look for embeddings of
features based on similarities over many
layers using an attention-based
algorithm
and a fascinating thing is that the same
algorithm that discovers structure and
language also discovers structure and
images
and now the tempting question is is
there an optimal algorithm that can
discover structure everywhere
and that maybe is recursive in the sense
that it it's starting to explore what
kind of strategies of discovering
structure are the best ones
and then it settles for those is there a
universal
recipe and i don't think that there is a
hope in the sense to say this algorithm
doesn't exist and humans will always be
better because if humans are better
than the algorithms that we discover
even the most
general one it means that humans are
implementing a more general algorithm
than the more general
most general one and we can discover it
right there is no reason why humans can
do something
that an algorithm that we write down
somehow
cannot do we can also write down the
formula for evolution and we can
in the worst case evolve the algorithms
that we need to and then
everything that we do is in some sense
an optimization of brute force evolution
where
we do a blind search and we do try to
find
uh directions in which we can optimize
the search and
for me this question is there this
optimal algorithm to discover choose the
optimal learning algorithm
that would mean we can't stop doing
science because as scientists we can
only now execute on this algorithm and
of course we can leave this to a machine
now and we should go to a beach and surf
instead and there's a factor of time
because we could implement evolution and
let it run for a billion years and then
it would discover something
that's greater than us in terms of
generalization but we probably wouldn't
need to because
uh the evolution that we are looking at
uh
is only slow for multicellular organisms
because in multicellular organisms you
need to
bootstrap the entire organism before you
can evaluate it
which in our case takes very long for
for us it's also necessary to train this
the new instance of the algorithm for a
long time before it comes functional
again right
if you want to breed the optimal
scientist you cannot just uh
vary our genome and look at the outcome
you also need to expand the issue so you
need to
incubate for nine months and then you
need to raise this
until it's in its 20s or 30s or 40s and
then you get an evaluation and then you
can decide uh which ones of those you
shouldn't uh
put into the next generation right this
is something that
is uh a result of the way that
biological evolution works based on
cells
in on if you just evolve single-celled
organisms it goes very very fast
right in a few hours you can have quite
substantial changes
and the microorganisms that for instance
we breed in our gut
are often quite specific trained for
tasks basically our gut is breeding
organisms to for its purposes and
that is done in reactors our
guts are in some sense breeding reactors
for microorganisms
and it's also a substantial part of our
nervous system
is uh duty bound to deal with this
breeding task with farming these
microorganisms all these
gut neurons are mostly dealing with i
think
maintaining this extremely large farm
that has specific organisms in it
and this works because it's uh such a
quick thing to breed
single-celled organisms but
if we build ai's in this way we would
not have to
reinstate the entire phenotype based on
a genotype
over a long time and retrain it we can
probably just change the parts that we
need and leave everything else intact
so the evolutionary research that we
could do in our technical systems
can be many many orders of magnitude
faster it can also be much more directed
because often we know what we're looking
for
so we can define a fitness function that
is very
close to the solution or that is uh
narrowing the solution space
dramatically
i remember you said that artists are
tuned to their
loss function something like that that's
what they're obsessed with
now the way that i understand that is
what you're saying is
artists are interested in their behavior
and what incentives and rewards they
have which are their values and they're
trying to replicate that or represent
that in some level
is that correct or is that wrong close
so uh what i try to say
is um that art is in some sense
uh a dysfunction sorry a what function
art
a dysfunction dysfunction yes because
so there are basically different ways of
looking at art
a non-artist a normal person a healthy
person
sees art as a tool it's instrumental to
something it might be tool for education
for entertainment for signaling status
for ornamentation and an artist and i am
from an artist's family and totally
identify with this stuff is a person
that thinks that the purpose of art is
to capture conscious states
full stop this is this is the purpose of
art it's this observation
for the sake of observation because the
conscious state is the important thing
that needs to be conserved
an artist is somebody who eats to do art
and uh a craftsman is somebody
who might produce artifacts uh but
uh they do art to eat right it's
it's very different way of looking at
things for them the art is instrumental
to to doing something the art is an
artifact and for
the artist it's a service it's a service
to something that is more important
than all the other things that you could
be
doing in this at the same time and so
if you see the artist as in with the
metaphors of artificial intelligence you
could say that
the mind of an artist is a system that
has fallen
in love with the shape of the loss
function it's no longer optimizing the
loss function itself
it's trying to figure out what it looks
like it's trying to capture
a certain structure for its own sake no
longer for the reward
that is going to increase as a result of
applying what you've learned
do you see yourself as doing that
yeah it's that's i think it's a
deformation and i can retrace it
uh in a way it's an identification that
happens at a certain level
for for instance my mind is a very
conceptual mind i perceive myself as
something that thinks that solves
problems that reflects
and i perceive as my emotions and my
body
as being outside of that for the most
part right emotions come into
me and they disturb me and i need to
deal with them and i need to make sure
that they don't distract me or that they
don't overwhelm me or
they don't kill me but i don't identify
for the most part as this emotional
being of course sometimes i go
over in that state and i realize that
state
in which you are this emotional being
that
is motivational and that is uh embodied
uh and experiencing that's the normal
state that we are supposed to be in
and a lot of scientists uh and
philosophers
are uh identified in a similar way
as me in a way it's the i think that a
scientist or an artist
or a philosopher is born when a child
discovers that it trusts its ideas more
than its feelings
and it happens often because you are
wired in a slightly different way than
other kids around you and as a result
your social interactions fail and you
can explain that
so you act like every other child based
on your intuitions
on on the 99 of what your mind is doing
and this training
and these intuitions are wrong what do
you mean when you say that your ideas
are different than your feelings because
obviously your ideas are some what
influenced by your feelings and your
perceptions
yes how do you disentangle them my ideas
are stories that i construct
they i have agency over my ideas my
i don't have agency over my feelings
before i'm in dart
when i'm a child my feelings are the
result of the interaction
between the model
that the mind maintains of the universe
and the model that it maintains of the
self according to the needs
of that self right so when
things happen in the universe the mind
evaluates them as good or bad which
means they're frustrate needs or they
satisfy needs
and as a result the self represents uh
joy or suffering
and when the mind is con
it doesn't have the correct intrinsic
model an innate model that you're born
with
and how to interact with the environment
then your needs are going to be
constantly frustrated
uh for instance i grew up in a forest
far remote from other villages and
when i got into first grade and met
other kids pretty much for the first
time
i had difficulty relating to them they
were not interested in the same things
as i was i was a nerd i was reading a
lot i was interested in
math and physics and science fiction
and history and stories and so on and
other kids were interested in soccer and
i couldn't get myself to be interested
in soccer and
as a result i was excluded from many of
the games
and later the same thing happened with
respect to politics it was eastern
germany
you were expected to pretend that you
conform with the prevailing ideas
and if you didn't you were punished and
even if these ideas were illogical and
at the same time your teachers told you
to be critical and don't take in all the
ideas from your environment without
criticism because you know
this is how fascism happened in germany
people took in bad ideas from the
environment without criticizing them
they did not develop moral agency so i
thought
the thing that i'm doing that i question
everything that i want to know why
something is the way it is and you need
to explain it to me
before i believe you um that would be a
virtuous thing
and so it was an apparent hypocrisy that
my
teachers told me one thing and uh i
behaved according to that and they
punished me if i did this
right it was difficult for me as a child
to make sense of that
and as a result i basically decided at
some level
and it was not something that was deeply
reflected but it was inevitable
to distrust my emotions i had to because
they were wrong
they were not pointing me in the right
direction i had to form theories on how
things work
and i think in a healthy mind this
development is temporary you
are a being that is directed by its
intuitions and these intuitions are
something that is uh
trained it's not something that is
random or superstitious
it's your intuition that tells you
whether this is going to be a good
relationship or not
but there should marry that person or
not but this person should be your
friend or not but
you should take this job or another
because if you try to make proofs about
this you're not going to get anywhere
it's way too complicated you're thinking
your ideas are way too brittle
and science is in some sense the part of
our
mind that is meant to deal with our
darkest and murkiest emotions
with those where we don't have solid
intuitions
right so it's science has marginal value
only for the individual
largely you need good intuitions it has
also only marginal value for society not
every ought to be a scientist
society wouldn't work like that because
science is too brittle the ideas that
scientists come up with don't tell you
what kind of relationship you should
enter and if you
overvalue science then your society is
going to go astray you need to have
solid common sense
you need to have good intuitions good
understanding of how things work
and only in those areas where these
intuitions break down where you need to
make proofs
this is where science really helps and
shines you mentioned that your intuition
is trained
trained by who and what your life is by
your experiences
so you're starting out yourself are
trained by society or both
no i think that society is is
often seen as too big of an influence or
i think that society is a small part of
the physical universe
and the thing that for instance trains
your intuition of how large an object is
when it has a certain distance from you
and you see it so so large on your
retina that's not given by society
right that's given in some sense by some
innate intuitions
but eventually it's given by learning
and you learn it by being embedded into
the universe when you have an intuition
of
how many steps you should take to catch
a ball that is flying
to you it's not society that teaches you
that it's
your interaction with the environment
that teaches you that and
so uh the same thing is also true for
social interaction
most parts of the social interaction are
not taught by society
it's your immersive uh you're being
immersed in the environment
that teaches you what to do and it does
so based on
mostly innate impulses that make you
interested for instance in the mental
states of others
and what they think about you and how
they react to you and in some sense
society is the result of those things
it's not the cause of those things
i recall you saying that in a repressive
environment like let's say eastern
germany
that artists flourish in a sense because
they have to constantly define
themselves
i don't see that as necessarily salutary
because
you then have to define yourself with
regard to the society so it's almost
like
you're a contrarian but then without
society you don't have an identity
you know when for example when someone
says i am
i'm counter culture okay but that means
you're defining yourself in terms of the
culture
not within yourself in other words
why is it positive for an artist to grow
up in an environment that
is intolerant or inflexible it's uh
often there's a motivating force between
the art and the artist and so
there is a topic that is motivating the
artist
uh to talk about and it can be many
topics that artists are on about
in a simple case the topics that the
artist is
obsessed with is the imagery
that is possessed in the artist it's it
could be just the
uh overwhelming force of
uh for instance musical patterns or of
uh
visual patterns just the aesthetics
itself that wants to have an expression
in that case the society is irrelevant
it could also be that
what's important to the artist is the
discourse with other artists
where there's a history of art and there
are certain movements in art and artists
are engaging with this movement and
of course these are the artists that by
definition are the most influential ones
but not all artists care about being
influential
there are many artists which only care
about their own inner imagery and this
imagery
has only an incidental relationship to
what happens around them
and there is also a lot of art that is
uh directed on the political or the
social and so on
it's not necessarily activism but it's
the relationship that the self
experiences in the contrast or in the
conflict with the environment
which itself gives rise to the
observation to the object of the art
and uh if you uh live in a society like
eastern germany it's a very interesting
point in history because eastern germany
had a weird economy
we guaranteed everybody a job we
guaranteed everybody
health insurance and a pension and a
home
and it sounds great yes and
uh i think it objectively was great in
some sense uh
the productivity was very low uh because
uh people were not incentivized
to work very hard because as a result of
working
very hard you didn't get better foot or
a better home or something like that
right so
people uh had maintained roughly the
same productivity as they did
as they did in the 1950s and it was not
the fault of the individual necessarily
it was the fault of how the entire
system was set up
so for instance uh the uh factories in
eastern germany
were commonly owned or nationally owned
this means nobody had skin in the game
there was no single individual that
stood to profit
if the factory was more productive and
if an individual was more productive
in a largely unproductive factory
it didn't have a big result on the
global outcome of society
it would only uh have a massive result
on the well-being of that individual
because
it was working very hard without uh
having a good result while everybody
else around them was slacking off
right so uh that was one of the big
issues and i think that ultimately it
was the economy that killed the east
the ability the inability to set
incentives for innovation
and uh this thing that you
have need to have a factory where
somebody has skin in the game so
somebody owns the factory and
profits directly from the results of the
factory
leads to a large inequality and as a
result to injustice
but we had the control group western
germany had this amazing injustice where
you have billionaires that own factories
and you have lots and lots of people
that work for the billionaires
and uh own a fraction of what they do
and have a life that is
arguably perhaps a fraction is good but
the point is the life of these workers
in the factories in the west was way
better than the life of the workers and
the factories in the east
because uh the productivity was so much
higher there were better consumer goods
and there was a better protection of the
environment as a result of the better
productivity
and uh there were more civil rights you
could
take uh holidays at grander beaches you
could travel the world and so on and so
on why does increased productivity go
hand in hand with civil rights
uh because there is more to go around
you can uh you have more room to
ask for things if you are better off
if once you are better off it's much
harder to oppress you because you
have alternatives to what is being given
to you
and in some sense once you have a
society where the individual is not
terrorized into compliance
then this individual will try to take as
much freedom as they can get for
self-actualization
and so western germany gave in some
sense more
a room for self-actualization to
the working class but uh at the same
time
if you were not interested into having
goods
if you were not interested in having a
big expensive car
if you're not interested in making uh
traveling the world and so on
then eastern germany gave more room of
for self-actualization to artists
because at a certain baseline you didn't
have to worry about existential issues
you
never had an empty fridge right you
wouldn't have fancy stuff in your fridge
but you would never go hungry you would
never have to be afraid that you
wouldn't be able to pay your rent right
so the hardest part just so
i can recapitulate the hardest part for
an artist is to make a living because
what you're doing
is you're making the art not to eat
you're eating for the art like you
mentioned before yes you want to have
space so you can do
yeah you want to have space for the
non-economical thing the the economical
thing is
the thing that the artist doesn't like
the ins to making art instrumental for
something that you can sell
is something that most artists don't
like most artists just want to be left
alone and do their art
and uh of course they need to eat and
they need to have they need to
have some sort of support structure and
so in some sense eastern germany uh
gave you all these things if you were
willing to resist the political pressure
and the social pressure
of playing along with the system if you
were willing to say um
you know you cannot do anything to me as
long as i have something in the fridge
and i just do my art uh that was amazing
right so you could uh
if you were willing to um say i'm not
part of this worker collective i'm i
don't want to have
a job in the factory and so on you could
do what my
father did and and he was sometimes a
child of 1968
he bought a house in the countryside a
watermill
and because he didn't get along very
well with society he was a nerd in some
sense without knowing what that was
and decided to have his own life built
his own kingdom where he wouldn't have
have these conflicts with the political
reality and the social reality of the
society around him
and could just have the life that he
wanted to which was painting and
sculptures and whatever crossed his mind
once you characterized fascism as a
super organism that doesn't care about
the individual cell
and if you're not contributing to the
whole then you're excised
and i was curious what's the difference
between that characterization of fascism
and
communism communism is tricky because it
didn't really exist right eastern
germany didn't call itself communist it
was
real existing socialism communism was a
utopia that we aspire to have
in many many generations but it was
basically our promise of the afterlife
that justified the present injustices
and
in accuracies and mishaps of the system
and so
i think that there was a big difference
between the socialist country that i
lived in
and fascism fascism defines the value of
the individual
exactly as its contribution to the group
which means if you are a disabled person
you should probably die because your
value is not negative
right if you are a person that is not
identifying as part of the group
for instance if you are jewish and you
have your own community
and your own values and your more
cosmopolitan and
bound to a cosmopolitan culture and not
to
the idea of supremacism of
white aryans um you are an enemy right
you
are a difference you are
something that lives inside of this
super organism and you should be removed
by its immune response
and so this uh extreme brutality of
fascism that is destroying everything
that is not itself
and that is it doesn't perceive as
valuable uh
is unique to fascism in a way and uh
especially when you do this at an
industrial scale if you do this with
modernist principles
there are other societies of course
which uh do the same thing as fascism
does which eradicate all the individuals
that do not have
the warrior tribe for instance or that
eradicate everybody who's a little bit
different
but they don't do this at scale and
the socialism was also a modernist
society
so it worked at scale but it did not
eradicate individuals
for being disabled or being different
there was eugenicism but
the eugenicism existed at the same scale
the same amount and roughly the same
time span as it existed in the west
right so in the 1970s uh disabled people
were often sterilized
because scientists decided or
society decided or some group within
society decided
that they probably shouldn't have
offspring because most of these
conditions were heritable
and would create liability in future
generations so the trade-off was
sterilized them and something that we
think now is immoral
but uh by and large you were not being
eradicated because you were different
eastern germany didn't have gulags as
stalin did
the golex were i think arguably as bad
as the
cut sets of the fascists and they uh but
they targeted people more or less
randomly
like stalin killed everyone hitler
killed those
that he thought were not detrimental to
the state that were enemies of the state
and stalin killed people on a whim there
was no safety in stalinism
there was uh some safety if you were a
proper
member of society in german fascism
and in eastern germany it was a rather
civilian society the number of political
prisoners uh
was quite comparable to a number of
western countries
so i would say that in terms of civil
rights and so on it's far
inferior to what existed in the west
in the western germany but it was still
one of the most livable countries in the
east and just by being different by
being an artist who didn't play along
you didn't run the risk to get into
prison
let's get to some of your powerpoint
slides is that okay
okay let's see if i can do some screen
sharing
okay so it says an architecture of
consciousness let's see there were a few
points in here that i was i wasn't sure
exactly about okay so construction
process c
changes the brain state so this is the
brain state x i at some point
then based on the brain state changes it
from x i
one minus one which is the prior brain
state cool okay
okay so that's like almost like an
evolution in physics where you have a
state and then you evolve it by one step
okay okay so then you have an
attentional process
that scans the current brain state and
records gender
okay what are the generative parameters
of x i so excise your brain state border
the generative parameters
i think this explanation is way too
technical i i know i think i have a
better way of explaining all this than
these slides
yes 2017 after all so uh
imagine that uh your organism is a
control system
so there's a big control agent that is
regulating your body temperature
and it's uh moving your limbs about and
uh it's
doing all these things in the pursuit of
food and social interaction
and all the things that are important to
you and it's basically like a big
elephant
and your consciousness is like a monkey
sitting on top of that big elephant
and is prodding it and the purpose of
consciousness
is basically a control model of the
attention
of the system and attention exists for
learning
so what does the elephant learn the
elephant
learns in two ways it learns in some
sense by
repetition and force right so if you
just repeat things often enough in the
environment of the elephant the elephant
might pick it up
and the other thing what it learns is
what it pays attention to
and paying attention to means you single
out some features
and you explore the relationship between
these features and these features can be
far remote to each other and they can be
very abstractly constructed right so
in some sense you to be able to uh learn
how to
dance uh you need to relate extremely
complicated features in the world you
need to
relate the expression of your partner
the music
uh the movement of your body uh the
social context in which the dance takes
place
and uh lots lots of things right and to
do all these things well you need to
combine them all into
a unique gestalt that is very hard to
express in this
simple specification so what you need to
have
is a way of singling out all the aspects
that go into the dance
and singing out the way in which you
have currently related them
and how you would need to change them to
improve that
and you need to figure out whether this
model of your attention where you should
direct it it was a good model and
whether you should change it and
so you should change what you pay
attention to right attention is more
fundamental than consciousness
yes then it comes before uh so
consciousness is the expression
of attending if you don't attend if
there is no attention
at all then there can be no
consciousness you can only remember
these things as having been conscious
that you attended to
right and also it's not sufficient that
you attended to them you also need to
store the things that you
attended to in such a way that you can
recreate them later in the context of
having attended to them so you basically
need to have an attentional protocol
that integrates over all these
experiences
and so you have an attention agent
living inside of the control agent
and this attention agent is basically
living inside of your mind
okay sorry sorry hold on so you have a
control agent and that control agent
controls the attention
no uh you have a control agent that
controls the organism at large
the big elephant okay okay let me you're
just you're teaching me right now this
is these are office hours
there's a control agent then there's
attention and the control agent controls
the organism
yes and the mind is the expression of
attention
the mind is uh in the way i use the word
it's basically the uh the software that
runs on your brain or that emerges over
the activity of your brain so it's the
entirety of the mental processes
and uh you could think of it as the
operating system
okay and there's a difference between
mind and consciousness yes so the mind
is the whole including the other
consciousness
yes okay okay and yeah so i would say
unconscious mind makes sense
as a term right so uh most of the of
what happens in the mind is
is not conscious yeah and there's also
uh
maybe we should go into this separately
but maybe we should do it now there is
this very big issue
uh what does it mean to be conscious
right it's
it's unimaginable that the physical
system like the clockwork could become
conscious
how would the physical system become
conscious something that
leibniz describes for instance uh with a
metaphor of a mill imagine that
your mind was like a big mill of all
these moving parts and so on and you
enlarge it in such a way that you can
enter it and you see all these
mechanical parts pushing and pulling
against each other
there is nothing in there over which
feelings and emotion and perception
consciousness could arise
and this is uh it's very strong
intuition that also drives
uh so earl's chinese room argument that
i think is a reformulation of
uh leibniz intuition pump here yeah so
what do you think of that experiment the
chinese room
so uh i think the difficulty is that uh
the uh it's a category mistake to think
that
uh consciousness exists at that level
so imagine you were trying to build an
artificial agent
that is conscious in the same way as you
and me are
you we cannot do this with the physical
system right the physical system cannot
be conscious apparently
so you would have to simulate it you
have to make it as if
to pretend to be conscious
how would you do this you would you need
for instance to have qualia qualia
are the features of experience there are
things like colors and sounds and the
relationship between them
and surfaces and the experience of
information flowing through space and
being hindered their pressure
and lightness and heaviness and so on
right and valence something feels good
or bad
and good or bad means that it forces you
to leave that state or attracts you to
that state and so on
and all these dimensions these feature
dimensions we can of course
implement as basically geometrical
models that we can compute
with formal systems of our choice
so it's there is technical difficulty in
how to get all these computations right
but there is nothing mysterious about
how to make a system that behaves as if
it would see colors
right it's going to not just measure the
wavelengths but it's going to generalize
the wavelength in such a way that it
normalizes over average highlighting
conditions says for instance red is
something
that passes as red under arbitrary
lighting conditions
on the surface of an object that is red
and that you generalize this over all
the red objects and then you also get
the associations to
blood and the flag of the working class
and to roses and love and heat
right all the rednesses are now one step
away from this abstraction of red that
can be translated as a feature dimension
as part of the
simulated experience of a virtual system
and so uh of course this experience is
not real there is not really any
physical system that
experiences anything it's only being
represented as if it was it's basically
like a multimedia story
it's not written in words in a natural
language or in a logical language but
it's written in
something like a machine learning
language and then this model is being
used to drive the behavior of the agent
it's a control model that is being used
to inform what the system should learn
and how it should interact with the
environment and as a result it produces
new steps that produces new model
contents and some of these model
contents are for instance thoughts
these are not real thoughts these are as
if sorts which means
there are conceptual and linguistic and
idiotic and imagined configurations of
such features
that give rise to the next set of
features to the next set of thoughts and
experiences right
again these are virtual they're not real
here the is what if the system would
feel something what if it there was a
person
what if there were social interactions
that would matter to the system
what if that would experience red in a
way that
corresponds to heat and so on right so
you build all this into the system
and you let it drive behavior including
speech
and self reports and it gives rise to
the next set of things
so this system would be
indistinguishable from us right
because it's also thinking the same
things now it's producing the same
thoughts and producing the same story
and it would have emotions and
experiences
it was experienced phenomena for the
same reason that a character in a novel
experiences it
because it's being written into the
novel by the author in our case the
author is the mind
and i think the answer to the big
question how is it that we can be
conscious in the physical universe is
we are not in the physical universe that
we only exist in that story we only
exist in the dream
that's written by the mind so this is
the
the way it works is it's virtual
consciousness is virtual
and the experience of realness that we
have is not the realness of the physical
universe because the physical universe
doesn't feel like anything right
reality doesn't feel real what feels
real is only simulacrum only a
simulation can feel real
to a simulacrum realness itself not
reality is a simulated property
consciousness is a simulated property of
a simulated system
a physical system cannot be conscious
only a simulation can be conscious
outside of the dream there is nobody
so we're conscious because we're part of
the story that the brain tells itself
yes the only conscious inside of the
story
and we are inside we are characters in
in a story that the brain is telling
itself
and we can talk across stories so here
we are
right now here's where i'm having
trouble because if i write a lord of the
rings for example
is frodo baggins actually feeling
something or is he just scribbles on a
paper just because it's a story
doesn't mean it has to have experiences
associated with it
so so why do we question is what do you
mean by
is right so uh this is the story
it sounds like it sounds like bill
clinton it depends upon what the meaning
of the word
is yes yes so it has to do with the
question of
uh what's being taken as the uh
of of reality uh i think that
reality that cannot be experienced is
very unsatisfying right it's not the
reality that most people would refer to
the experience of reality is something
that is virtual it's something that's
it's the experience of the vr generated
by your mind
right it's a virtual reality that you
inhabit as a non-player character
and the non-player character is
generated by the mind as well
to describe the interactions of the
organism with the world
right it's a story about what the
organism does in the words the best
story that
the mind can come up with and this story
is being used to inform the behavior of
the organism
and you cannot break out of the story
that's why the story is real to you so
the the thing is to uh to frodo
his feelings are real in the story to us
they're not
because we see this from the outside we
see how this thing can be constructed we
can even change the story if we have a
pen and paper
and can make him feel something
different but
to frodo himself it doesn't make sense
that his feelings are real to him
unless we write into the story that they
suddenly don't feel real to him anymore
right give me a scenario where you can
write
and make a conscious being
from your writing of a story do you just
write
frodo now feels so and so and then frodo
actually does feel so and so
so it doesn't work with natural language
you have to use a functional language
that
is it's basically not just giving rise
to a description of
what photo is doing but you need to have
a functional implementation
of an agent in an environment right so
you need to have something like a
representation of middle earth and you
need to have a control agent inside of
middle earth that is being controlled by
a frodo self
and photo self is a model of what frodo
is
and it's a model of basically the
affordances of that agent and the state
of that agent that is driven by that
control model
and so this control model is going to
contain
thoughts that are the result of produce
interaction
with photo's environment and the
thoughts
when photo is implemented properly will
reflect on the needs that this agent has
and the needs uh are in the agent
because they're being programmed into it
right it behaves according to these
needs and the if the model is adequate
and is con conforming to those needs
then this model is representing uh
pleasure and pain
in such a way that voter would describe
them similar to
the way that we would describe pleasure
and pain and he would describe them
as his thoughts because that's the best
uh implementation of its control model
that photo's mind can come up with
so the language that is being used is
not a natural language is not
english words or something it's a
functional language it's
a programming language in a way
so can you then take that and stimulate
a small consciousness
let's because we mentioned that it's
extremely complex to do something like a
human at least at this
at least in 2020. can we make a small
conscious agent
i think that we can but if the agent is
too small
it's very difficult to ascribe an
interesting type of consciousness to it
and the biggest difficulty is if you
have a conscious system that is not able
to attend to anything meaningful that we
can relate to
how can we say that it tends to anything
and in a way the biggest unsolved
problem of artificial intelligence is
not consciousness
it's understanding and understanding
means that we map
everything that we perceive onto a
unified model of the universe
more or less unified but it's uh we
basically
explain something by creating a
relationship to a unified meaning
and the unified meaning is our model of
the world and
everything that we perceive we are able
to integrate into this model of the
world
and this is something that our ai
systems are so far incapable of doing
everything i think we are getting there
but uh yeah
is understanding predicated on
consciousness
or do we not need consciousness for
understanding
and it depends a little bit on how we
would define understanding
so uh to understand something in the uh
it's often
seen as a verb that means there is a
relationship between the
one who understands it and the thing
that is being understood which means you
have to have a self concept
and and a system that can attend and uh
the self concept needs to have a
representation of the fact that it's
currently attending
and what's in the focus of attention and
i think if
the question of whether a system is
conscious comes down to the question of
whether it has a functional model of
what it's attending to
and the fact that it's attending to it
right so
uh you have to have these two aspects
there's contents of attention
and the fact that you are currently
aware of them you using this attentional
process
once you have that i think it makes
sense to ascribe consciousness to the
system
have you heard of the other theories of
consciousness like the integrated
information theory
and daniel denetz and so on what do you
think of them well let's go iit
i think that iit is several things so it
starts
out if you look at the axioms of iit
with the
phenomenologist description of
consciousness it describes what
consciousness feels like from the inside
so for instance you have this
impression over here and now and this uh
here and now
is distinct from the physical here and
now i think
something that uh iit as far as i'm
aware doesn't really emphasize but it's
pretty clear
that uh from the perspective of the here
and now in consciousness
uh the physical universe is is not in
that here and now
and cannot be because we often construct
the conscious experience
after the fact or predictively
which means the the here and now of
physics is smeared out
right and we are able to experience
things consciously that
don't happen physically not just because
we are simplifying them but uh because
we
feed emerge the features of our models
in a way that is not compatible with the
physical universe but that is useful
to the control of the physical universe
so basically the contents of our
consciousness are determined by what
makes up useful control model
not by what's physically possible and
what's physically happening
the other aspect of iit is
its denial of functionalism so iit in
some sense
is makes metaphysical assumptions
and these metaphysical assumptions i i
suspect amount to pancychism
which means that um consciousness
is in some sense inseparable for matter
or from the background of the universe
therefore it must be an intrinsic
property of matter itself
you could say imagine you cannot just
determine what color is and if you look
with the microscope is you cannot
see what color is made of right color
doesn't have components so
uh color must be an intrinsic part of
matter color is not made by matter
it's inseparable for matter every matter
contains color
right right this is almost correct but
it's not because
if you zoom in at a certain point there
is no more color
color only makes sense as a kind of
interpretation of
what we sense about matter and i think
that's also true for consciousness
right consciousness only exists within
minds not within the physical universe
and so in some sense iit i think is
putting the locus of consciousness into
a domain where it doesn't belong
and then there are the technical aspects
of the implementation of
uh the i t series iit
that is this factor phi the measure of
integration
and uh there are some good aspects about
this uh so
in the sense that uh your own neocortex
is uh integrating information in such a
way that when a lot of it is
synchronized
and is stored uh in an intentional
protocol
then you will probably have a larger
focus of your
attentional awareness than when you have
when your uh consciousness is highly
fragmented and your
this will be reflected in the
fragmentation of the cortical contents
which means
that a lot of it is not firing in
synchrony and this is being described to
some degree
by phi but uh this is a relatively small
aspect in this
of of phi and i think if you go deeper
and try to make
more out of phi then it falls apart
because you it's no longer necessary in
sufficient condition
you don't know what gradual states of
phi mean and so on
so i i don't think that i buy iit at
this point it's not explaining how this
phenomenon comes about
and it's uh descriptive and it
has metaphysics that cannot be evidenced
that are not predictive
um the next thing was donald hoffman i
by donald hoffman's first part of the
theory which is typically
the world looks nothing like what we
experience it as
that is obviously the case and
the second half
i don't follow it's a uh depends on
in which way you look at uh what he
writes and spells out
so uh the second part to me is the thing
that
computers are an inadequate
representation of what our brains are
doing our brains are not computers
there's something else
and i think this results from a
misunderstanding of what a computer is
there so he's he's driving the intuition
here that a computer is a digital von
neumann machine similar
to a pc and our brain is not organized
in
in the same way as our personal
computers are
our brains are self-organizing systems
there are
oscillators and they use very different
ways of translating
the information between the different
parts and
achieving coherence and so on than our
digital computers are
but this doesn't mean that they cannot
be described as turing machines
the turing machine is too general for
that thing basically
you're looking at a finite state machine
that can be used to compute
representations and
execute control functions and the brain
is
clearly in that category and what we can
show mathematically is that these
uh the different instances of that
category are equivalent to each other
which means
there are mappings you can take a
digital computer
and create a simulation of the brain
a virtual brain in that digital computer
that behaves in the same way
in principle and also in principle vice
versa
so you can create a simulation of a
digital computer in a brain
but it's this is much much more
difficult because our brain is
largely indeterministic so it's hard to
get enough determinism from the brain to
keep a model of a large digital computer
stable in it
and so we can only run relatively small
digital computers
in our brain but using external tools
for instance if we are allowed to use
pen and paper
we can use our uh analog
or our chaotic and independentistic
brains to run pretty large simulations
of digital computers
but externalizing the memory and
determinism
what about douglas hofstetter's idea of
consciousness the strange loop i'm not
sure if you're familiar with it but what
do you think of it
and do you mind explaining to the
audience the idea as far as you
understand it
i don't think that i can adequately
explain it uh
to me hope stutter is
found about to a tradition of uh
computer science that is uh taking
girdle as
talking about a property of the
languages that he still try to use
so he's not a proper computationalist he
is
using classical semantics to describe
computational system
and it leads to contradictions in his
descriptions
and i think that the strange loop is in
the class of these contradictions
and i i think that our consciousness is
not strange
as a loop it's there is some loop going
on but it's not a strange loop at all
it's a loop that goes between the
contents of the attention
and uh paying attention to the fact that
we still pay attention so we notice that
we haven't drifted off
so the strange loop sorry the strange
loop doesn't exist there's no such thing
as a strange loop because it's
predicated on false mathematics or at
mathematics that doesn't apply so
yes but i am not sure if i represent it
adequately and i would have to reread it
and
properly formulate it so i am reluctant
to
talk about it because i cannot properly
translate and define it here i would
have to
uh look it up again yeah no problem how
about the holonomic theory the holonomic
brain theory
oh it's a long time that i stumbled into
this one i didn't quite understand how
it was explaining consciousness so there
is a certain way in which
it is pointing at the hierarchies
of perception that we have and that's
accurate but
uh i i haven't understood how the
holonomics theory explains consciousness
in the sense that i i didn't see a
specification that i can implement and
end up with a conscious system
how about daniel dennett's idea of
consciousness
or at least his explanation is to how
consciousness arises and what it is
i think that danette as far as i
understand than it is
uh there's nothing wrong with what
danette says ever
the incredible person that that uh
so the things that i read from him i
don't have any objections
except that he seems to ignore the part
that most people struggle with
which is phenomenal experience so
basically he does
make fun of the people that explain
how mary proves that
machines cannot be conscious and he's
justified in making fun of them and
it's a very good read but he is not
going to convince any of these people
because he is not deconstructing the
thing that they are struggling with
which is phenomenal experience
he is mostly seems to be ignoring it so
it's incomplete it's correct
but incomplete i yeah i suspect that he
doesn't think that there's that much to
explain
because he uh may not have that much
phenomenal experience he probably has a
fantasia
only speculating here it could be that
basically uh
then its mind is so conceptual that he
doesn't think that there is that much to
explain
and there are people which are rarely
visiting the conceptual realm
and they make the have the experience
that the this
logical language is unfit to describe
anything of consequence in in
real everyday life so how could it
explain something that is so fundamental
as
a phenomenal experience right you need
art to describe that
and uh danette is so far removed in the
way that he speaks talks
things operates that his own mind
operates that it's
very hard i think to see for the
phenomenologists
how dennet is actually talking about the
same thing
but uh having said that i do think that
danette is right
it's just he is not giving us a
specification that we can implement at
this point then again he's a philosopher
so he's not uh dealing with the
specifications very much
uh and so when i read done it i
i don't object to anything that i read
so far but uh i also learned very little
it's basically trivially true but it
says
how about the sensory motor theory so uh
what does it mean to have a sensory
motor theory of consciousness i suspect
that there are a number of
people that would refer to sensory motor
integration
as at the core of consciousness and
you could say that there is crucially a
notion of agency that results
from performing actions
and sensing the result of the actions
and making sense of the relationship
between
actions and perception
when i was confronted with this notion
i i thought well how do you know that
there is action
what exists is eventually just a notion
of perception
have you heard of bergson's theory of
consciousness
wait let's let's go yeah sorry sorry
let's continue with the sensory motor
thing if
you're still yeah no i apologize i took
your pauses
as as you were finished no no um
my bad by the way just in case i'm a bit
loopy i
i haven't had enough i haven't had sleep
proper sleep in like three days and i've
only eaten one meal in 72 hours
approximately
because i'm in the middle of a fast so
if i seem a bit drowsy or
or slow please forgive me
i have no difficulty forgiving you okay
why don't you continue about the sensory
motor
uh so i suspect that we discover our
body the motor aspect only through the
senses so it's
basically we discover the control
architect architecture we discover
that there is a relationship between
the environment and certain states which
we
notice as being intentional states and
the body that is the instrument of
translating intentional states into
changes in the environment and this
control hierarchy of
intention
originating and motivation and needs and
then
this leading to the initiation of motor
actions
and the initiation of motor actions
leading to physical actions
or mental operations and then as a
result to changes in the world in the
perceived
external world or in the perceived
mental world and this again
leading to changes in our needs and
motivations and so on
this this discovery of the loop is only
possible because we have the entire loop
given
if any element of this loop was missing
we would not be able to discover our own
agency
right we only discover our bodies as
being that instrument
we wouldn't discover that we have a body
outside of volitional states and
environment we wouldn't discover
volitional states
in the absence of a body and the
environment
and the body could uh also be a mental
body that
is able to perform mathematical
operations that's probably sufficient
for this
but you will need to have to see some
outcome of your actions
and something that some way to affect
these outcomes
to arrive at the notion of your own
agency and the type of intelligence that
makes us distinct
is the ability to conceptualize
ourselves as an
agent embedded into the universe our the
generality of our intelligence is given
by us having to solve control problems
that are so general
that we need to model ourselves that we
need to reverse engineer us right
imagine you start out with the
thermostat
and this a thermostat is a system that
controls the temperature in a room
based on a measurement of the
temperature and a control impulse that
turns a heating element on and off and
now imagine that this uh
thermometer is very close to the heating
element so there is some feedback
between the heating element and the
measurement that you make
and if you want to get the temperature
in the room right and don't want to run
into viral fluctuations
you might need to have a second order
control loop and the second order
control loop
is basically correcting the measurement
that you're making with your sensor
for the activity of the heating element
which means
now your second order control loop will
have to uh
implement a model of the interaction
between heating element and heater
and it might have to implement a model
of
the temperature of the heater itself and
how much this contributes to the
temperature in the vicinity
and the second order control group is
what's conscious in this example
no it's just a second order model no
it's uh so basically we are now looking
at a nested system a nested cybernetic
loop
and if you have a room where you for
instance have a changing volume of
air because you sometimes open the
vendor or not
you might need to have a third order
control loop that is now
measuring how the heating element is
changing the temperature of the room
depending on that third
hidden variable and you try to guess at
this hidden variable
and now if you also have temperature
fluctuations on the outside because
maybe you have a change of season and
the air that comes in
uh and out now that might require more
complicated loops right
and eventually you will also need to
have a model that describes
the uh sensitivity of the heating sensor
and
the inaccuracies of the heating sensor
and maybe
the at certain temperatures the switch
doesn't operate at the same
rate as it would uh happen at uh your
default temperature right
so you need to allow for the
quirks of your own control architecture
and this means that at some point the
control loops have to model the system
itself
so you get to a system that is modeling
its own place in the environment its own
relationship to the environment
consciousness is not yet related to this
consciousness is a tool
to discover this imagine you have this
vast multitude of possible measurements
and
possible hidden states that you cannot
directly measure but you have to
construct
to explain the data that you're
measuring the relationship between them
and because you have this vast
conflagration of possible relationships
between them
you cannot just do a blind search
instead you need to have some kind of a
directed search something that is
structuring your search and telling you
which of these
parameters you should single out and
relate to each other and uh
try to change the relationship see what
the outcome is and so on and that
is the purpose of consciousness is the
direction of attention
over this multitude of possible states
okay so the purpose of consciousness is
the direction of attention
but also at the same time you said that
it was the story that the brain tells
itself
so in this thermostat example what is
the story that's being told
so the story that could be told about
the thermostat would be that
there is this thermostat or a measuring
system
that is regulating a parameter in in the
world that relates to other parameters
in the world
for instance volume of air outside
temperature frequency at which a window
is being opened
maybe other agents which open and close
the windows uh
maybe other agents that change my
settings depending on what's happening
and so on right and the more
data you can integrate the more complete
your model of the universe will get
the more parameters of the universe you
will have to integrate
and at some point you get to a model
that is complete in a sense that
you have a smaller set of causal laws
basically physical laws that are
sufficient to explain the conditions of
your existence
and the basic uh principle that explains
how everything relates to everything how
functions are being computed how a
system can exist in the universe how a
universe can be generated
and how a system can change itself as a
relationship to that that is computation
so computation gives you a language to
talk about first principles
and what is intelligence in this is it
just the ability to model for the
generation of
more models whether or not they're
predictive or whether or not they fit
yeah what's a call intelligence the
ability to make models
but of course it this makes sense in the
context of a control task usually so
there is a certain control task that is
being fulfilled
and the intelligence of the thermostat
would be
measured by the complexity of the models
that the thermostat can build
as a result of the interaction between
the data and the measurements
and its actions is there a relationship
between intelligence and consciousness
such that the higher your iq as an
individual let's say as a human you are
more conscious
i would say that consciousness is a
solution for creating certain types of
models
so it's basically an aspect of a certain
class of algorithms
of algorithms that require the direction
of attention
in a particular way and so
the fact that we can recall having
attended to something
while being something that was attending
and while being aware of the fact that
we were attending instead of drifting
off
uh right this is what determines our
type of consciousness
and it's not necessarily the case that
every system
has all these degrees of freedom or
needs to have these degrees of freedom
to be able to solve
the same problems as we do because we
could just fixate these things
maybe we can have an attentional system
that is itself unconscious
when you say to solve the problems are
you referring to just propagation of
existence that they don't die
no our death is unrelated to this our
death is a concept that exists it's an
idea that our word line is broken in a
certain way that it ends
and we are not continuous in the first
place our idea of
existing in a continuous fashion is a
construction that we have over our
memories to explain
memories that we seem to have of past
states
sorry continue continue whether three
will come in
free will is a representation isn't
envisioned in the system that
it's made a decision and the decision is
being made on the best understanding of
what's correct
and a free will is uh
it's basically it's uh the out flow of
this control task it's the outflow of
the
control uh algorithm being executed in
the right way
the opposite to free will is not
determinism
if you are indeterministic you cannot
have free will if you behave randomly
there is no will involved
right it's just random and the opposite
to free will is also not coercion
because you are deciding that you are
giving in to the coercion
you wouldn't need to be coerced if you
wouldn't have a degree of freedom
but the opposite to free will is
compulsion
it's basically when you do something
despite knowing better
the opposite of free will is compulsion
as well as randomness
uh so uh randomness is the absence of
will at all
right the system that is random has no
will so the will cannot be free or not
but so we have to look at the opposite
of the freedom and the opposite of the
freedom is not the coercion it's the
compulsion
that's when the system the compulsion
means that you have a model of what you
should be doing
but you don't find yourself acting on it
you find yourself acting on something
else you are acting on based on some
impulse or some addiction
and that is basically the true
impingement on your freedom
but it's important to realize that
freedom is not an absolute
notion in the physical sense it's it's a
reference that we make to certain
internal states
so when i refer to my own decisions as
being the result of my free will
depends on the context in which i use
this and when i talk about the
experiential context
experience by will is free when i have
the impression
that i made the decision based on
parameters that are the right ones that
are in the proper order
with respect to the control structures
that my mind currently implements
and not because of uh some glitch in the
matrix of some glitch in the system that
implements me
or uh of some erroneous programming or
some
uh external force that is spreading in
my mind
so uh when people have the impression
that they inter
act uh out of a compulsion for instance
because they say first and have anorexia
they might decide to
or bulimia they might decide not to
throw up after eating but they cannot
help themselves they just have this
enormous urge to throw up or make
themselves throw up
there's nothing that they can do about
this and it's a very disturbing
experience because it impinges on your
freedom there is one thing that you want
to do
and another thing that you find yourself
to be doing
and this is a very big existential
disturbance that happens in that case
okay so freedom is like you have a model
then you execute on the model based on
the parameters and it's salutary and
it's positive
what does positive mean that it fits
your goals
it typically does right so imagine you
have your frodo in
your middle earth world and it's a story
and we imagine we implement this as
a computer simulation like a minecraft
middle earth and you have your photo
agent in there
and the photo agent is acting based on
models that photo is creating
then photo would probably conceptualize
his actions as being the result of his
own free will
if he has the impression that
everything happened in the way that it
was supposed to in his own mind
that is he is perceiving certain things
there are certain things he wants as a
result of his
physiological social and cognitive needs
and spiritual transcendental needs maybe
which i think may be understood as a
class of social needs
and as a result he is doing certain
things he's making certain decisions
because they increase the likelihood
that he is reaping the anticipated
rewards with respect to his needs
and if this all happens in the proper
order then his mind will represent
i wanted this the intention is being
represented
and i wanted this because of a mechanism
that was only determined but what by
what i needed
and what i consider to be the right
thing which defines my own freedom
so it's in some sense a paradox the more
you know what you ought to be doing
the more agency you have and the more
freedom you have subjectively
but the fewer degrees of freedom you
have and the less you know what you are
doing
the more degrees of freedom you have but
the less do your actions mean anything
which means you have less objective
freedom or because you have less will
so is free will a story that we tell
ourselves part of that it's a model
right in a sense it's a story that we
tell ourselves
but it's not we who do this it's the
mind who tells it to the self
it's upstream from the self your mind
cannot control what experiences
at its own will except in certain states
at one point you mentioned that the
dalai lama can
effectively live forever in the sense
that he identifies with the government
and as long as that government
is instantiated and not dissolved then
he lives in some way shape or form
okay i didn't quite get that do you mind
explaining what do you mean that he
identifies with so and so so uh what i
mean is not this
i said i meant s so uh most of us
identify as a person in the sense that
we live for a certain time span
uh we have certain organismic needs we
have a physiology
we have social relationships to our
environment
we have relationships that we serve we
have a greater whole that we serve
that gives rise to our spirituality and
so on
and all these things define what we try
to keep stable
what we perpetuate the thing that we try
to control the control system that we
are for this is where we are the
thermostat for right all these
dimensions of needs
a few hundred physiological needs a
dozen social needs
a handful of cognitive needs and uh
keeping all these in balance
gives rise to our identification the
identification
is a result of us making models of how
these needs relate and so we create a
hierarchy of purposes
the needs themselves are not sufficient
we need to have a model of what is going
to give us pleasure and pain
and this is what we would call a purpose
and their purposes need to be compatible
with each other
and this hierarchy of purposes that we
end up with is
in some sense our soul it's who we are
or what what we think we are what we
think of as ourselves
and we change this hierarchy of purpose
yes of course we can we do
our in our because of our life it
changes so for instance um for most
people it changes radically when they
have children
right and what i mean is can we
consciously direct it
yes directly it's just like it's the
mind there's something behind us
that's producing us and we're just
players in this game
yeah we have the feeling that we're
controlling it but we're actually just
being told what to do
so we can control it in such a way that
we uh
identify pathways in which the models
that are being created in the self or
as contents of the self inform future
behavior
and of course there is the self itself
is not an agent it's a model of that
but you can experience that uh from the
level at which yourself is constituted
you can change the identification of the
self this is basically keegan level five
where uh an agent gets agency not just
over
the way it constructs its beliefs but
also agency over the way in asian
constructs its identification
and colloquially we talk about these
states as ones
of enlightenment because we realize that
the way things
appear to us that these appearances are
representations
now things are not objectively good or
bad that but that there is a choice that
happens at some level in the mind
whether these things are being
experienced as good or bad and that we
are responsible for
our reactions to things and the way that
we react to things is instrumental
to higher level goals that we might have
and once this happens we can
learn a number of techniques in which we
change
how things appear to us so uh for
instance
uh when you do the dishes this might uh
so you might find it horrible to do the
dishes because it takes time away from
you
it's uh it makes your fingers wet and
sticky and
it's annoying and so on you could also
realize
it's time out for you where you just do
a very simple
physical tassel itself is pleasant
because it's nice and warm on your hands
your body doesn't hurt while you do it
and you get some time to contemplate
and you need to do it anyway and you can
turn this into a time that you enjoy
right and you can get agency over the
simple thing
so this sounds like in self-development
where they would say just reframe your
problems into something positive so
let's say you have to run
you're you hate running you just say
well i'm doing something that's good for
my body
i like it yeah so the the question is uh
are you just telling yourself a
different story consciously or do you
experience the story as being different
and so their intended result is
that something happens upstream of your
experience which means you now suddenly
experience doing the dishes
as pleasant intrinsically pleasant it's
not just you're talking yourself into
uh some kind of a delusion
that uh makes you pretend that you like
right so how do you cross that barrier
because if you just tell yourself well i
like this task i like this task even
though you hate it
you feel like you're being
self-deceptive and it doesn't work
so how do you actually get it so that
you experience positive emotion from it
in that case it's super simple you just
focus on those aspects of the task that
are
that for instance contain sensory
pleasure
and uh there is uh and the aesthetic
pleasure of being able to follow your
own thoughts where you do something that
does not bind your attention very much
and is not directed on
say work goals or family goals or
something else
right so you can uh enjoy the mental
freedom that you get and you can enjoy
the uh pleasant aspects of the sensation
of the warm water and the soap
and the movement of the hands and the uh
softness of the cloths that you use for
cleaning and
the hardness and of of the things that
you are cleaning and so on and the
sense of cleanliness that you are
creating in the world and the aesthetics
that are
involved in that process in the same way
if you
don't want to do the dishes because the
things it takes attention from you
you can focus on the negative aspects
and uh by
emphasizing this in your attention you
basically uh
put a spotlight on this part or that
part of reality
and you make you emphasize the parts
that you experience in there right so
you can get
pleasure aesthetic and sensory pleasure
from a task
and you can get uh sensory horrors from
it and aesthetic displeasure from the
same task if you focus on different
aspects
of it if it's a matter of changing one's
focus from the negative to the positive
how could we
seldom do that if it's so positive i
mean if it's so
net positive to look at a task and just
focus on what's bringing you sensory
pleasure
why don't we do that i suspect that we
don't have intrinsic attention on this
for the most part because it would not
be useful if we protect ourselves in
this way
maybe there is a reason why we don't
like doing the dishes or we like doing
the dishes
that we are not wise enough to discover
and if we could just reprogram
our reaction to things before we
understand that reason
uh maybe that would be premature and we
would end up in a local optimum in the
way that we organize our life
where we end up being a dishwasher when
we should instead be a lover
or an artist or an explorer
or a an intellectual worker right
so maybe it's too early to to reprogram
your experience
before you know what you're actually
doing i see so you have to come you have
to understand yourself because there
could be
an evolutionary right yeah okay i
suspect evolution would have given us
the ability to reframe our experiences
fundamentally if that would have been
useful and the fact that it's not is uh
if you treat yourselves into
experiencing whatever you do as pleasant
too early it might make you very happy
but also dysfunctional
you also mentioned once that your theory
of consciousness is something that we
intuitively know and that when you tell
people
they had a suspicion and for some people
when they stumble upon this insight that
you also
elucidate that they get
depersonalization disorder
it can go two ways where they feel
liberated or they feel
distance from their body and it's and
it's net
wretched and ruinous for them what do
you say to those people
who who feel disidentified from there
who don't feel identified with their
body and it's not a positive experience
what advice would you give them i would
advise them to go to a real therapist
because i'm sadly not a therapist i'm
not competent of doing this don't listen
to me if it gives weird experiences in
your body
i have cannot take responsibility for
what's happening to you
so uh i'm just a cognitive scientist i
that would be super dangerous i think
and irresponsible
if i just try to create weird
experiences in your body
as a result of my theories so i would
say this is a side effect
and it might be a side effect of you
trying to answer a
question that i have myself and me
answering this question
doesn't lead to weird experiences in my
body
and the i have yet experiences in my
body because i exist
right existing is weird and i want to
explain why is it possible that they
exist that
experience that i have a body why is it
that this body sometimes feels very big
and
uh and unveiled why is it sometimes
extremely small
why does it sometimes disappear how is
it possible that i can have an out of
body experience
i want to explain all these things and i
find plausible explanations that all
make sense
and are much more logical than the
inverse of these explanations
right so i i find them helpful and
what i can offer people is suggested
solutions to similar question that i
have and i might be wrong with my
answers
they're the best answers that i can give
at this point in my life
and they are compatible with the answers
that
most of the other thinkers give that
have looked into this they're also
largely co-extensional with the answers
that a lot of meditators give
it's only that they are using a language
that
seems to be incompatible with the
language that we have established since
the enlightenment in our own culture
it's basically uh there is a disconnect
between
what we experience as being real and how
we talk about reality
in our culture and this makes it so hard
to make sense of consciousness
and feelings and fundamental experience
and identity
and transcendence and so on and the goal
that
i have when i give these explanations to
myself and others
is to explain how we can get what we
experience as being real
and what we also
observe as happening around us in our
interaction with the environment
and the way that we reason about reality
how we can put this into one how we can
construct the metaphysics
that is compatible with our scientific
worldview
and that allows us to make sense of what
we experience
what about people who fear losing
control that as soon as they have this
insight that the mind is just that you
are just a story within your own mind
that you don't have control now you say
well we have control but i'm
i'm unclear as to how as to who has
control seems like the mind has control
and there's some relationship between
the story that you're in and what's
telling the story i i don't see that
connection
so they never had control in the first
place yes and i mean you see this every
day right there are things that you do
that you would prefer you wouldn't do at
least most of us are in that state and
unless there are perfect sages in a
there was tradition
where everything that they do is in a
complete union with their perception of
what the universe
needs to have done at that point and
most of us don't get to this point it's
very hard to cultivate your mind
to this union where you have an identity
between you
perceive what needs to be done and what
you do
and uh this discrepancy is something
that we have to explain and we can only
explain it
as as as not being in control and
meditators describe this as the
monkeys trying to prod the elephant and
the elephant
just walking its way as it wants to and
sometimes it's aligned with what the
monkey sees and thinks is important
but by and large the elephant follows
its own wisdom
do you have any advice for someone who
finds that disconcerting that the
elephant is more in control
uh i think it's uh try to not take the
monkey that seriously and try to
sense what the elephant is doing and
realize that it's a much much larger
dance than the dance on the
of the monkey on top of the elephant but
uh
and it's also a larger dance than the
elephant itself it's the
entire forest right and the elephant
being part of it and being in resonance
with it interacting with it
and there's only very few decisions uh
in proportion to the entire thing that
is happening that can actually be
controlled
and they can only be controlled in
certain ways and what you can
explore is in which ways you can create
a coherence
between what you perceive that needs to
be done the global aesthetics of the
universe that you prefer the way the
forest should look like
and this is a part of your task is to
figuring out these aesthetics
how can this universe be coherent and
consistent and
as a result beautiful and what is the
things that can be controlled
as part of it locally and
you are the result of that you are not
the cause of that
you are the result of the local control
you are not the thing that causes the
low
control now the local control you
mentioned intuition earlier that it's
important
to follow your intuition and i assume
that
intuition a component of that is your
conscience your heart
is that a part of the elephant so in
some sense
you should stop trying to direct the
elephant and follow the elephant as the
monkey
well you need to do both but ideally you
want to have a state where the elephant
is treating the monkey as one of its
most useful tools but of course not it's
uh it's only one and uh the
um monkey needs to be able to shut up
from time to time
and it can give the elephant feedback
especially when the elephant needs it
and so in some sense there should be a
friendship between the
monkey and the elephant in the sense
that the monkey waits until
it has its task and its time and the
elephant is actually asking it for
something the purpose of reason
and analytical thinking is to repair
perception and when i mean intuition
i mean perception because we mean that
it's the purpose is to repair
perception perception is the
part of our mind that is integrating
information
in a way that is not linguistic and not
conceptual
it means the integration is not discrete
it's an integration that happens over
many many features often in an
irreducible way
or in a way that we don't yet understand
imagine the way that you integrate
information when you try to catch a ball
right you see how the appearance of the
ball changes in your visual field
and as a result you learn how to move to
catch it
and if you try to do this analytically
if you try to
compute the model with the capacity that
your mind has you're not going to be as
effective
than when you are using in perceptual
model which we would call intuitive
right you
train your intuition of what movements
you should be making
to get the ball and when this is
systematically not working
okay and you can use your uh reason to
figure out what's going on
okay or when you are already very good
and you try to figure out is there a way
in which i could do it better
right then you can use your reason to
construct a system that is measuring
your movements and using camera and
optimizing your technique or uh or
simpler things like finding a better
trainer
right right right okay so there's a
mismatch between what you want and then
what you get
and the repairing is yes this is what
reason is for it's basically for dealing
with these edge cases
is there a way to falsify or test your
model of consciousness
i think that there is a way to test it
in the sense that we can at some point
build a system
that will explain that it's conscious
to others that that would be the
ultimate proof
and to itself and that there would be
nothing left to be explained
wait wait sorry sorry if it just says
that it's conscious then it's conscious
this is so so the question is whether
you build it in such a way that it
cheats
right so you could of course make a
chatbot that pretends that it's
conscious without being conscious
and but this would mean that at some
point you will see a functional
difference
there will be a difference between the
behavior of a conscious system
and the behavior of a system that is not
conscious
and i think currently that the
difference that you would observe
is that the system does not have a
control model of its own attention
it's not aware of the fact that it's
attending and what it is attending to
so for instance the question is a cat
conscious i think is a decidable
question it's a question that comes down
to
whether the cat can be best explained as
being aware of what it attends to and
based on this criterion i would say cats
are clearly conscious
and if you look at a sleepwalker a
sleepwalker is a person that is unaware
of what they attend to
they can attend two things but they
don't know that they do this and as a
result they cannot question their
actions
they cannot redirect their attention
they behave
in a way like an automaton because there
is
this attention loop is missing that
would be able to reflect on what they
are doing
and learn they can walk yes but they
cannot learn
they cannot change their behavior as a
result of reflecting
on the interaction with their
environment they cannot direct their
attention in this sense for this
attention learning
they can perform all the automatic
autonomous behaviors
that the elephant has been trained into
they can
there are perceptions taking place right
they can open the door they can even
make dinner but they are unable to learn
something
so they're able to coordinate actions
but it's like an orchestra without a
conductor
so capacity to learn as well as
attention is what's required for
consciousness
and somehow this becomes a test of
consciousness that you can falsify it
from this
i think that the ability to learn is
neither necessary nor sufficient you
have people that are conscious and that
have lost the ability to learn
and you have systems that can learn
clearly
they're not conscious but i think the
the purpose why we have this attention
is largely to enable us to
do a targeted recall of indexed memories
for the purpose of learning
is it ever possible to get a continuous
perception from
a discrete phenomenon so what i mean is
let's say we're just bits
zeros and ones and it's binary discrete
yet we perceive continuity smoothness
okay
how can smoothness come about from
discreteness
the trick that our brain is using
because our neurons don't act
continuously right the neurons involved
tend to fire at rates of like 20 hertz
how is it possible that we see a
continuous movement
and the trick that our brain seems to be
using is that it uses keyframes
and vectors that tell it how to compute
the next keyframe
and you can see some evidence for that
in two ways
one is um there are optical illusions
where you have a static image that is
seems to move on the page
and if you have such an optical illusion
it shows that there is the difference
between
the appearance of movement and the
change of location
right if something was moving
continuously you would expect it to
change location
but if something can move without
changing location it means that your
brain is representing the movement
separate
from the change in location the change
in location is the difference in the
keyframe there is only one frame right
that you don't look at different
keyframes
when you look at a static printout of an
optical illusion that moves
if you see it moving it's because you
only perceive the vector of movement
this means it's a static representation
that applies to the single frame
and tells you where you would expect the
thing to be
if it was a changing location and the
second evidence is that there are people
which have brain lesions
uh that uh lead to a stroboscopic
representation of reality which means
they only perceive the keyframes but
not the movement between the keyframes
okay so let's forget about external
sensory experience and what if you close
your eyes and you
visualize in your mind's eye a circle so
you see that as smooth
now are we just wrong in our perception
the circle is actually not smooth we've
tricked ourselves somehow
it's actually jagged like pixels if we
were to zoom in
how is it that we can get smoothness
even internally i would have to look at
the real circle because i have a
fantasia so i have a circular light up
here and i can see
it as a smooth in the sense but the
smoothness is mostly the absence of
a detectable non-smoothness
right so basically i can use a function
that describes
the progression of the line using this
smooth circle and i don't notice
features
that go away from that simple function
and i want to have a more complicated
function to describe an object that has
jaggies right so in some sense the
smoothness is a decision surface between
features
it tells me where to expect more sensory
data it tells me where to expect
certain blips on the retina or on my
mental retina so to speak on my mental
stage
when i imagine that object so it's
basically some kind of generator
function
that tells me in which way i expect the
features to fall
but it's not something where i
i can only see the jaggies if i expect
to see jaggies
and this can get confirmed in some way
right and the jaggy function the one
where i see
the aliasing or corners and so on needs
to have an explicit representation in a
certain way if this representation is
absent
then i will only see the smooth surface
how has your view of consciousness
changed in the past few years let's say
four years
uh i think that i focus it's basically a
shift
in focus it's the shift that uh goes
away from the
phenomenon experience itself um to
uh what gives rise to the phenomenal
experience
and uh especially the way attention is
implemented as in
as opposed to control in general and
uh so i would say that i get closer to
an implementation
my view of the femininology of
consciousness i don't think has changed
in the last few years
so my phenomenology of consciousness as
a result of observing
consciousness of zooming in at different
layers
of resolution and observing altered
states for instance the
dreaming states at night and when i do
lucid dreaming or the hypnagogic state
between dreaming and waking in the
morning and so on
do you practice lucid dreaming i did
this in the past
but i don't do it systematically anymore
i suspect it's not functional for the
brain because it's in some sense like
inducing a trip in your brain similar to
taking drugs
uh because you are forming long-term
memories of things that you are not
meant to
form lentil memories about basically
there are several modes
of learning one is a simple uh
conceptual learning where your
perception doesn't change but the way
you relate your perception is changing
and there is another one where you
change the construction of reality
itself
the way that you construe reality and uh
if you go to this level uh if you also
change the way you relate to the
environments you need to deconstruct or
suspend yourself and your agency and the
boundary between self and universe
and i suspect that's uh one of the
reasons why we have these dream states
in which we don't react
or interact with reality itself right i
remember you saying that dreams might be
something akin to generative adversarial
networks and i'm curious to explore that
what do you mean how does that come
about
so in some sense we are producing um
hypothetical realities that can predict
sensory patterns
and we have a system that acts as a
discriminator that
tunes these generations of degenerative
functions
to see whether they are able to explain
sensory data
and the most important discriminator is
your perceptual apparatus that is
uh connected to your sensory input
that is your retina your cochlea and so
on so
by enlarge your thylamos which is the
big switchboard that connects
the different brain regions and your
sensory input
so and in some sense your imagination is
being used to predict sensory data
and the set of functions that is closely
predicting the next batch of sensory
data is what you experience as reality
but it's a dream every experience of
reality is in some sense a dream state
and the dream states at night are
different from the green states during
the day
mostly in two aspects one is in
if you unless you do lucid dreaming you
don't have a consistent sense of agency
which means you cannot recall who you
are and you cannot really direct your
attention in any way
there is no subject involved there might
be a story about a subject
but the subject is not doing things that
can be controlled by the subject
and in the lucid dream you bring this
agent online you gain a sense of agency
and the sense of control
can direct your attention according to
control parameters right this means now
you have a system that is exerting
control based on
uh the expectation of maximizing some
kind of reward and some of the
dimensions that your mind cares about
and uh but at night the second thing
that happens beside the agency is you
are no longer in touch with your sensory
apparatus
so you have no way to access what's
happening on your retina anymore
in the external world yes so uh
everything that plays in your cortex
plays out on your cortex
is now originating in your cortex there
is some slight interference with the
sensation
of color or whether you need to urinate
or smell
smell translates relatively well into
dreams for most people
but by and large you cannot sense what
happens in the outside world
and this is not going to enter your
dreams in any consistent way instead you
are only
going to use your mental representations
to make sense of other mental
representations
if dreams are for learning why is it
that we don't remember them why does it
go away uh it's largely because dreams
play out as situations
uh of things that has never happened but
we do that all the time in our own head
when we're just thinking about
speaking to someone like a boss like
what am i going to say to that boss how
do i get a raise how do i get
not get fired yes but all these things
are prefaced as this doesn't happen
this is an imagination of an imaginary
situation i'm playing out the following
things
these things have will happen in reality
in the following way
and then you can compare them with
reality and you can use this to tune
your imagination to make it better next
time
whereas in a dream your construction of
reality itself is changed for instance
you see objects from perspectives that
you've never seen them from
you might be have a flying dream as a
result right you see the world from top
down perspective
and as a child i think many children
have playing dreams for that reason that
basically your brain is generating new
perspectives of known objects
and so you can recognize them from these
new perspectives that's uh
it's very useful but it's not very
useful to remember that you can fly
because you can't do you know of any
studies that have been done
about people who can recall their dreams
versus people who can't and if they
report higher life satisfaction if any
of those
groups no i'm unaware of that
so i don't know how uh if people that
you can recall their dreams
are happier than people that can't and
uh
i suspect that uh it should be possible
to
change the equilibrium of most people
that cannot recall their dreams
in such a way that they can or to wake
them up at the right moment and
that they will be able to remember their
dreams if you uh
wake them up during ram faces but i'm
unaware of these studies i'm not a steve
scientist
if if all we did was dream is that real
well all we do is dream in a way right
so every perception of reality is a
trans state it's a dream state
there is no reality that is it can be
sensed
it's only this vr that you are
entrenched to believing that it's real
it's a movie that your mind is showing
to the self and the
self is recording in some sense what
happens at its boundary
with this intentional protocol and we
can uh partially recreate these binding
states later on
as the memories of states that you think
you have been conscious of
and this is all there is this is only
the stream
let's end this on a positive note with
you saying
with you telling people how like almost
instructionally how is it that
from your insights from what you've said
how do you get from that
to then changing your mind so that you
experience positive emotion or at least
a negation of negative emotion there's
none an absence of it
i don't think that you should sort
emotions into positive and negative ones
i think that you should look uh whether
your emotions are helpful or unhelpful
and you should have the most appropriate
and helpful emotions that you can have
not the most positive emotions that you
can have
the purpose of life is not to
be happy in a sense that you should be
in a state of constant bliss
you should be able to achieve the things
that matter to you
and the emotions help you for that so
uh but see you should check whether uh
your emotions for instance
express ruminations which means you
might be caught in a loop that is
unproductive and you're just
veering a groove in your mind rather
than making progress
you should see whether you are suffering
which is usually a result of you trying
to change something
that you cannot actually control at
least not in the way that you're
currently trying it
right so this is what you should be
monitoring you should monitor
the trajectory of your emotions and see
whether they are still helpful
but they're your tools and just turning
your tools into
something that only gives you one site
is not helpful
so how do you control your tools to make
them helpful
it seems like you do this or do you
struggle with this
oh i struggle with this i'm probably not
the best person to ask
okay here's one of the reasons why i ask
when i see you you're extremely positive
and most cognitive scientists that i
talk to they're neutral
neutral to positive and you're almost
always happy
it seems like you're in you're not
perturbed you're not easily perturbed
you're
you're equable uh
no i think it's a useful state for
communication
and a lot of people that have to
maintain an academic position find it
extremely useful to
uh look like a professor right it's a
culture you have to
maintain a certain gravitas if you uh
come across
as a a friendly person uh or as a
humorous person
uh that might limit your impact and with
certain audiences right are you really
the person that deserves this funding if
you
uh are goofy in some way right yeah so
uh of course i don't want to be goofy
but i also don't want to scare you and i
want us to
uh have a straightforward uh friendly
um and maybe even loving conversation so
i'm trying to open myself to you and i
try to build a personal relationship and
i find that
uh kindness and friendliness and humor
are useful tools for that
i also find that humor is often a useful
tool to deal with your own suffering
and kindness and friendliness so instead
of basically using graphness to
enter your suffering that is typically
something that pushes you out of the
area which you would need to deal with
and humor is sometimes a tool that
allows you to
make an area of your mind that you have
to explore because you need to repair it
more bearable
is there any principle that's higher
that's worth dying for so far
like it sounds vague but for example you
mentioned that the machines
will likely win or let's imagine there's
a scenario where they win let's just
hypothetical
then merging with them if we want to
survive is what we should do
but is surviving what we should do what
if the machines win and part of the
machine's goal is to take over
the entire planet i know we've done that
but let's say they do it in a
in a way that causes excruciation for
most of
life but we say well we want to live so
let's merge with them
should we do that is there something
else
that's more important than simply
propagating
i think that something can only be
important if the mind makes it so
the physical universe by itself has no
importance whatsoever
life by itself has no importance
whatsoever
uh from the perspectives uh
that my own statistics give me i think
complexity is valuable
and mainly maintaining complexity over
long time spans is desirable
and so basically having a state in which
you
see the continuation of life at high
complexity on this planet
seems to be a desirable thing to me on
the other hand life
is excruciating for most conscious
beings
for most of the time in some sense
existence is
by itself not necessarily pleasant if
it's consciously experienced
even though it's a constructed thing by
the mind itself
and so i don't have an absolute answer
to questions like this they only need to
be framed by a certain context
in the context of having children i will
give you a very different answer than
by the context of looking at the
planetary ecosystem
right so uh depending on on that
particular context for instance
what do i wish for my children or what
do i wish for my friends
how they should explore existence or
what do i wish for
um my species or what do i wish for the
ecosystem that i'm part of
these are uh very specific questions and
for these specific questions
no yeah of course they are and in some
sense ethics is about the negotiation
between these conflicts
but they all are predicated by a choice
that you
need to make in the beginning the choice
of what is important to you
and initially we don't make that choice
because we have innate choices that
evolution has
done for us and that are solidified in
our interaction with the social
environment and so on
but eventually we get to the point where
we get
agency over these choices and where we
can deconstruct them
and then the answers become complicated
and there is not a single answer because
the answer
obviously depends on the system that you
are
right if you become a machine so to
speak if you
uh identify with a different system
uh for instance in this way that the
dalai lama identifies as a form of
government
as an institution a thing that
or the queen to some degree identifies
with the crown
which is an institution it limits her
actions as a human being the queen is
not free to do
what you and me are doing the dalai lama
is not free to do what you and me are
doing
because he operates on different
constraints right these constraints
give him both more agency and
fewer degrees of freedom in a certain
way and they also free him from worrying
about certain things because
to the degree that you identify for
instance with your family
you are free to worry about your own
individuality within the family
to the degree that you identify with an
ideology you can
disidentify with your personal ideas to
the degree that you identify
with being a form of governance for a
group of beings you can identify with
this single individual that you are and
it doesn't really matter if you die as
long
as you are reborn this form of
government in a new individual that is
performing the role as well as you can
or even better maybe
right so this who am i what is this
thing that i stand for what is it that i
identify as is not necessarily related
to the substrate very tightly
the same way as the software does not
need to identify with the hardware that
it runs on
you are not identified with your brain
you are identified with the things that
you care about
and as soon as you get agency over what
you care about you can say that the
choices that you make are more or less
consistent with each other
and they are more or less compatible
with the choices that others make
but there is no absolute answer anymore
what do you identify as
it depends i am not identified as the
same thing in every state
and sometimes i identify as a father
and sometimes as a lover sometimes as a
partner as a friend
as a coworker uh as uh somebody who
thinks
as somebody who struggles as somebody
who doesn't want to live anymore
somebody who wants to get some sleep and
nothing is as important as that and so
on
let's explore that one where as someone
who doesn't want to live anymore because
i'm curious what if someone says
i think what's most important is the
destruction of life i don't think it's
worth it i think that the amount of
suffering is not worth the pleasure
and you're saying that objectively
there's nothing wrong with that so what
if they come to that conclusion
and they pursue it is there
yeah what if they do that that just it
sounds like it's objectively
wrong but you're saying uh that's fine
just pursue what you want as long as
it's important to you
so yes uh i can only object to this to
the degree that it is
conflicting with my own goals and for
most people that would be the case and
so they legitimately would uh give
opposition
there's also this issue it's very very
hard to sterilize a planet
life is extremely resilient even let's
just say they dislike humans because
humans are the ones that have betrayed
them in the past
yeah the humans are going to take care
of themselves at some point right this
species is not immortal
uh we might already be on the way out
and of course there are individuals
which
um the individual might fall
out of this and uh
peterson describes this as uh the
uh school shooter got angry at god right
and uh i think that god in in this way
that peterson has been using it in this
sentence
is the uh platonic form of the
civilization that somebody is part of
it's the greater whole seen as a
sentient agent
the relationship of this individual to
this god is the relationship that the
cell has to the organism
and are you a plaintiff no
but uh so in some sense there is an uh a
practical sense in which i'm
a platonist but i'm not a platonist in
the intellectual sense
so i don't think that these categories
exist
beyond being more or less coherent
models but
i think that as a learning system i
i need to believe that there is
something at the end of the gradient
right there is going to be a certain
model that i can approximate that
describes reality optimally well
given my resources and starting point
and in this sense i have a strong
experience of platonism that these
categories are real and
so in this context it seems that we are
a state-building species we are not in
species of solitary individuals unless
you are a sociopath
that is does not have any sense for a
greater whole and most of us have this
sense of
feeling that we are functionally part of
something that is more important than
us as an individual and this would be
the implementation that you would need
to give a cell if the cell was conscious
and was able to make sense of its
relationship to the environment
if the cell is part of an organism and
not a single cell organism
if you as organisms don't actually exist
right
organisms are away to think of large
groups of cells
that act as part of a greater whole
they act sorry when you say organisms
don't exist you mean to say that they're
just a collection of molecules that move
in a particular way and we model them
as organisms an organism is a function
that describes the interaction between a
group of cells
and it's a function that is different
from a bunch of cells because it
says that some of the cells are not
helpful to the organism rate is a
function that describes
a control structure there are cells
which don't belong to the organism even
though they are in the same region
and some of these cells even share the
same genome
and but there might be tumors for
instance and the organism tries to get
rid of them
and so the organism is in some sense a
function that describes an order
and the same way a society or a
civilization is a function that
describes this order
and the organism if you look closely
only exists approximately
right because you cannot describe
everything that happens there
using that thing if you look at reality
you only can do this
in a hypothetical space where you reason
about what also cells are doing
and the same thing is true for society
or for cells
and this notion of the emergence of a
society that is entirely coherent
where the behavior of all the
individuals has sense
with respect to the greater whole this
coincides with the invention of the
concept of gods and i think they are
basically the same concept
it's the idea that individuals can
interact in such a way that their form
and agent on the next level of
description and this agent is sentient
it has a relationship to the world
around it
as goals and a relationship to its
constituents to the parts
and you can see in the history of the
religions that this relationship to the
constituent parts changes
right the old abrahamic god is is really
a mean [ __ ] he doesn't care about the
individuals what he does to job
uh just to uh prove a coin point to the
devil is
uh horrible right from the perspective
of
an individual but from the perspective
of an organism doing something to its
cells it doesn't matter at all
right of course the organism is able to
do things to its cells and the cells are
not supposed to care about this
because they belong to the organism they
are owned by the organism they only
exist
by the grace of the organism and for the
good of the organism it reminds me of
what you describe fascism is like
yes exactly and the idea of for instance
the introduction of jesus christ and
catholicism
was necessary to deal with a religion
that was compatible with the roman
empire
so you want to have a society where you
already have pax romana and every
individual has something like its own
dignity
and its own role regardless of the
society
and you need to make a good offer to
these individuals and you need to
structure the relationship between the
individuals and allow them to grow into
the part of the organism
so you introduce humanism and the entire
idea of
jesus christ i think is the introduction
of humanism
into this hebrew religion and of course
the hebrew religion has changed later on
and became more humanist
in other ways but i think that
originally the invention or
the introduction of the concept of jesus
was exactly this humanization
of this uh resulting hyperorganism
and we have been selected to be part of
an hyperorganism people that didn't play
their role in the hyperorganism and were
unwilling to subscribe to it
they were often killed right they didn't
have a lot of offspring
and we did this for a period of many
many generations literally over more
than a thousand years
and so most of the people that live
today
on this planet are the result of having
grown up in such
systems of organization and so they are
selected for these systems of
organizations we are all
selected for feeding part of something
that is much larger than a tribe or a
family
we are part of a transcendental greater
whole of
of some civilization and the old word
before enlightenment for this
civilization was god
we are reluctant to use this word
because it's so tainted by the
mythology of the cults that we
invented or that were invented to
stabilize the civilizations
right the religions invented mythologies
that are not possibly true that don't
have evidence going for them
and cannot have possible evidence like
creator gods cannot have evidence for
them
you cannot observe as an inhabitant of
the universe act
that relates to its creation and any
statement thereof will only be a mental
state
that the individual has not something
that is a valid experiment
that tells you something about reality
so gods are
mental constructs they are about as real
as selves which are also mental
constructs
a god is the same gods are as real as
you
in the sense that you are a mental
construct yes gods can
are basically selves that span multiple
minds
and the greek gods are good good
examples for that so the greek gods are
stable
because they are all archetypes they are
all certain
extremes of psychology or connections of
extremes of psychology that give
rise to some kind of a human archetype
and this makes them immortal you can
refer to them
across human beings and you can treat
them as if they would exist
and then they are the demigods like
hercules
who exists because he has stories that
make him immortal
but this thing that you can live in the
mind of another person or of an organism
and move from one mind to another one
this is what
makes you a god in this conception of
the greeks it's not the normative force
that our religions had
and in our religions the identification
of a god is not just it's an immortal
superhero comic
character but it's some kind of
archetype instead
it's uh it's a singular thing it's
monotheist god
uh or it's a subset of it that is like a
limp of that god
that is describing what our civilization
ought to be seen as and the relationship
that we have to that god is
established for instance in prayer
prayer is an activity in which we
meditate about the properties of god and
the relationships that we have to god
and thereby establish god and in the
process of prayers
gods can even become conscious if that's
part of their specification even though
they use the hardware of the human brain
of the individual human brain so in some
sense prayer works
even though the god doesn't exist in the
physicalist sense
it exists in some abstract sense yes of
course the prayer changes the
relationships that people have to each
other and the identifications that
people have they change what people
think is right and normal and good and
what they want to do
and they change the way they interact
how they share resources do you pray
first
no you meditate yes and
i could say that there is maybe
everybody prays in a certain way in the
sense that we try to
spend time in establishing our
relationship to the greater whole and
reflect on that
so i would say that in a very secular
way i'm praying
but i grew up in in a world where
the religious cults were seen as
repulsive because they are antagonistic
to rationality
and i take issue with the
anti-rationalism of the way the
mythology of religions is enforced
so somebody who forces me to believe
things that are manifestly untrue
just to have a checksum on my mind that
distinguishes me from non-believers
is violating me that's why i cannot be
part of such a cult
at least not in my present state i can
only be part of something that is
compatible with being rational
and this means retaining autonomy over
my
identity and over my thoughts and over
my morality
and over my beliefs without that
morality identity i cannot be part of
something
and i there are groups that act like
this
and you could say that they are
spiritual that but they're probably not
religious at least not in the
traditional sense because they don't
have organized religion for the most
part
but so uh to get back to this a person
who wants to end all life it tends to be
a person
who is not disinterested in life it
tends to be a person
who does take an interest in the greater
whole
because uh the actions of that
individual affect other individuals
right
they want to end life and experience for
all of them right and so this means that
there is a relationship that this
individual has to the greater whole
and it's one of uh disenchantment it's
one of opposition
it's one where that individual decides
that
the greater whole is not good that it's
not worth it that it's doing something
that is
morally unjustified and this can happen
right if you're for instance if you're a
kid that is
mistreated and bullied by everyone and
you don't have a space in the world at
all
and you decide it's not your fault and
so you should die
but it's everybody else's fault and the
way that everybody else plays and
maybe it's the way that everybody else
is organized by the forces of the
universe and evolution and you can just
not make peace with that
maybe you radically oppose it and you
want to end it
and that experientially might uh
manifest itself as
running amok so it's a result of not
just a loss of meaning but an inversion
of meaning it's
it's an inversion of this spiritual need
that people have but it's still a
spiritual need can you expound on that
it's an inversion of the spiritual need
i think that uh in our society that has
lost
its future and uh you cannot have a
civilization without planning for a
future because this is what a
civilization is for and about
right in the niche in sense of the death
of a higher value
uh no it's basically a civilization is
the thing which makes you
build a cathedral over 500 years it's
something that allows you to act on
long-term plans it's something that
allows you to organize things in such a
way
that your grand grandchildren will have
a way of living
and we have given up on that our future
is changing much more rapidly than our
models of the future and so we have
stopped tracking the future
but what we can track now is that there
is not much future left possibly at
least we don't see how it can play out
well
we don't have strategies to deal with
the existential problems that our future
is bringing
we realize that the summer is awkward
that's
one of the worst summers that we ever
had but we also
realized that this is going to be one of
the coolest summers of the next hundred
years
we are unable to imagine what the summer
of 2025
will be like and when we think about it
we are terrified because we don't
prepare for it we don't have ways for
dealing with something that is worse
than the status quo what is that this is
spirituality
so basically we live in a world that has
lost its future
and as a result we have lost our culture
and so our spirituality our innate need
for
being part of a culture that is giving
rise to a sentient civilization
this has become a phantom limp and
that's why people are drawn to
superstition to
uh to feel that phantom lamp so this
phantom lamp attaches itself to
ideas of a conscious universe or of
immaterial deities that uh care about
you in some
magical way and uh
this is all of course [ __ ] this is
uh
this is really the expression of that
phantom lump the thing that is
is real is this is life on the planet
it's the ecosystem
and it's our part in the ecosystem and
it's our civilization
that organizes us as part of that
ecosystem
and if we cannot maintain that then
everything becomes meaningless and we
notice this loss of meaning
what do you disagree about with peterson
you mentioned peterson's
conception of the high school shooters
as saying they
are objecting to god and you said well
that's correct in some sense there are
many many aspects where i don't uh
really agree with peterson it's i just
referred to him because he
uh is one of the few public
intellectuals we have left for better or
verse right
i'm curious what ways do you defer we
talked about dennett and you you said
you disagree with him in some sense
because he's incomplete
what about peterson that's more
commission right that's more old mission
rather than commission
uh i refer to peterson because he is a
common point of reference we all know
about him right now no that's fine
that's fine but i'm curious where you
disagree
so um and where you
agree yes so uh yeah the interesting
thing is
for me when i have to talk about
disagreement because disagreement is the
default state
between mines isn't it it's only where
we can establish agreement
when we are independent thinkers where
we
see that we uh understand things in the
same way
so uh peterson thinks that the best way
to
interact with a cult that tries to be
state religion with some kind of
aggregate war
is to make a stand and to expose
yourself
and uh i am not sure if i agree with
that
so basically he is fighting a cultural
war in an ineffectual way i think there
is also a deeper level
peterson thinks that growing up consists
in making a sacrifice
and the sacrifice is self-actualization
he would like to be happy but he cannot
afford to be happy but it was it's
incompatible with being an adult and
doing the things that an adult has to do
and his sacrifice is incomplete he has
not sacrificed his need for
self-actualization
and that's why he appears to be so
bitter right
if he had made the sacrifice he wouldn't
be bitter
would sacrifice sacrifice of
self-actualization yes
so he would become a priest
he would have that serene state of
somebody who has not lost anything
because he doesn't need anything
what he doesn't have right this if you
look at the
archetypal priest it's a person that is
serene
that is smiling because they are at
peace with themselves and the world
and they might be suffering momentarily
because the unbelievers
crucify him but apart from the moments
of
acute pain or the
moments of compassion for their flock
when they are involved in their
dealings with the world and try to help
them and fail at doing so because not
all things can be helped
right the priest is supposed to be okay
with what he does
and peterson is not okay with what he
does he is
suffering because he uh has retained his
identity
that the one that he thinks he has uh
sacrificed he hasn't
yes basically trying to understand it
i'm trying to understand this so you're
saying that
he has an identity and because he's
holding on to it it's like a want and
you should get rid of your wants and
then you'll be
placid and serene and tranquil yes
so he basically he's doing something
that he has not fully internalized
himself
he is expressing the tension between
what he thinks he needs to be doing and
what he does
and what he feels would reward him for
doing
that right he he feels pain in doing
what he does
and uh there is of course this uh other
thing that uh
he is acting on certain incentives in
this game
and the question is uh are these
incentives completely pure
so he is a publicist that is filling a
certain niche a certain vacuum
he is uh trying to give people values
uh he is trying to a protective
authority in a time that needs authority
and he might not be projecting exactly
the right authority of fitting authority
but he's interacting with the fact that
the millennials are the first generation
since
uh the post-war generation that are
authoritarian again right every
generation
after world war ii was liberal why are
we authoritarian
um i think that the millennials became
authoritarian because they realized that
liberalism has failed them
it has failed at uh saving the
environment at uh
offering resources and
self-actualization to everybody
so now we need to go to some
authoritarian system where we control
what people think and feel and how they
interact
and the result
of the world the insufficiency of the
world is no longer seen as the
uh absence uh the result of the absence
of freedom right the
post-war generation saw that the
problems of the world were that we
didn't have enough freedom
we needed to uh free individuals for
instance we we should have
the ability to engage freely in love and
sexuality
to self-actualize and the problems that
we had in relationship was because we
didn't have enough
freedom in our relationships and now and
now
uh the results of injustice in the world
are
seen by many millennials as the result
of a surplus of freedom
well oppression is the flip side or
referring to the
that's that's privileged or this yes yes
it's basically the uh the now the issue
that we
need to fight is privilege we don't need
and privilege is a surplus of freedom
and if we can remove the privilege as a
result
we get less oppression in a more just
world right but it also means basically
we have to limit the self-expression of
the
of people and this is opposed to
liberalism
what if they say that hey we just want
freedom for ourselves you have freedom
all we're doing is trying to
promulgate freedom just to those who are
on the oppressed end
yeah then there would be liberals there
would be people like for instance uh the
gay movement in the 1970s which said
uh you have freedom to marry for
instance and we also want to marry
right but social justice is for instance
uh if you are uh heterosexual you cannot
kiss in public because that's
heteronormative
i see yes and it's insulting those
people which cannot kiss in public
right and uh if you have an ability uh
to
do a certain thing you cannot uh
construct
a life around this ability because
that's ableist
right so instead we have to level the
playing field we have to build a society
that gives a
level playing round to those which have
no ability
and this leads uh into some apparent
contradictions but ideologies have no
difficulties with this contradiction and
the main issue is
that the rationality of this liberal
system is still a rationality that even
though it's internally logically
logical is a rationality that doesn't
serve most people
and it seems to be something that
peterson doesn't seem to understand
you cannot force people to abide by the
logic of a system by which they lose
but why should they play a game by which
they lose why should you create criteria
for getting a job
that require the equivalent of an
aptitude test
that you fail and if that job is the
only way that you can feed your kids
right uh if for instance becoming a stem
scientist or a machine learning engineer
is one of the main ways that you can
have social mobility and late stage
capitalism in the u.s
and you limit this to a certain subset
of the population
isn't that massively unfair to most
people in society and so why should most
people
subscribe to the criteria by which you
give out these jobs
and so you will find yourself with a
movement that's the answer what's the
alternative
i don't know what the answer is but i
think that
so i suspect that peterson is not going
to solve the problem
right he is telling these people you are
wrong then you try to change the
criteria for how we give our jobs in
stem
but he is not addressing the reason why
they want to change the criteria
and the reason is once more the reason
is social inequality
the reason is that they don't know how
to feed their children
so so is ubi an answer
uh i don't see a systemic order in which
ubi works
so i i think that if you want to
introduce ubi you
ought to produce a simulation
of the economic environment in which the
ubi is sustainable
i think that ubi is the attempt to
perpetuate a system
under changed conditions at the moment
uh wages
salary is the way that we allocate
resources to individuals
right and they are also a way in which
we evaluate the
value of the contribution of the
individual to society
and uh they are a way to discipline
individuals and their way to integrate
individuals into teams and groups into
society as a whole and measure the value
of their contribution
and as soon as you automate things and
globalize and outsource
uh this falls apart and this is what we
witnessed to some degree
it never worked perfectly well but now
it works
less than ever because we have more
productivity than ever and people don't
live better than ever
and so how do we deal with that and
so the idea is we give people salaries
but they are
independent of what they contribute to
society
and independent of productivity and uh
this
is probably sounds like great for
artists yes
of course because artists are largely
not going to change what they do
so uh in some sense if you give an
artist
a salary they are still going to do
their art because they are intrinsically
motivated
and uh it's very difficult to force an
artist to not do art
at least the artists will suffer a lot
and the artists will
typically play along with society
arguably a society that
consists entirely of artists will not
work very well
because many of the other things will be
left undone
right and a lot of society requires that
people do things despite not wanting to
do them
people that collect the garbage probably
need to be paid very well and they
deserve to be paid very well because
nobody wants to do this voluntarily
unless it's your own garbage and nobody
else does it then
of course somebody will eventually need
to do it so
how can we perform this allocation of
resources how can we make sure that the
garbage gets collected
and how can we make sure that people
have skin in the game in our larger
enterprises
in a system where we have ubi so i
suspect that something like a citizen
income
where you uh have community based income
and communities decide uh what kind of
labor you perform and this money can be
given out as stipends for instance if
you want to write a book and your
community says yes sure write this book
it's a useful thing to do
uh right uh but but we still have a way
to
allocate people into nursing jobs or
into social interaction or into
community management
or into education i think that would be
a good thing to have
i see a big danger in the
particularization of society if people
no longer feel as part of a greater
whole
and just see that society is that thing
that feeds me but it's something that i
don't need to put
things back into and uh
to uh think that ubi uh is going to
magically achieve this because people
have an intrinsic need of doing that
it's probably not going to work out
because they as if there is no force
ultimately for doing that over multiple
generation there's going to be drift
if there's to make you contribute to the
whole society yes
then eventually people uh will stop
contributing to society because of the
drift
our opinions are not intrinsically moral
there is no intrinsically moral power in
the universe
it's ecological if an opinion is
possible or if a behavior is possible it
will exist
if it's incentivized it will be abundant
and
if it's not helpful it doesn't matter it
will still be abundant
it will just mean that the system breaks
down and so uh
but i like the idea of ubi but in some
sense
the artist in eastern germany and so on
did have ubi
and we basically had a right to work but
we were not really forced to work in
eastern germany
and as a result we went bankrupt our
society went bankrupt
like literally and the houses that we
lived in they still had the pock marks
of the last war because in 40 years we
were not able to get enough resources
to fix the houses even in our capital
berlin
right it's ridiculous we always set a
shortage of labor for instance
the west had an enormous surplus of
labor and often didn't know
how to get people into gainful
employment because the productivity grew
but the population didn't shrink
and there was still labor competition so
working hours didn't shrink
and as a result a growing number of
people got unemployed because we were
unable to allocate labor in an efficient
way
in the west and in the east people we
just
absorbed productivity by being
unproductive
and to some degree this also happens in
the u.s right the healthcare system is
the most expensive system in the world
and it's largely because most of it
consists
from unproductive things in documenting
transactions
and most of the things that people do in
the u.s is arguably documentation of
transactions it's the biggest
part of employment apparently and so
people work very hard very long hours
and they still live in houses made from
tyvek and plywood have bad water
and have health care that makes them
bankrupt
and so the big question would be how can
we change this how can we implement
an architecture of systemic incentives
and i think that
ubi is not part of systemic thinking
it's only dealing with a single symptom
at a single level
and this is not the right way to
comprehend society you need to zoom out
and understand the superorganism
and is ai the solution or gai i think
that ai can help
definitely it can help in making com
simulations and models of extremely
complicated
things but there is also a difficulty if
we
start to compete with ais as individuals
and as
groups and as societies you're probably
going to lose if we
succeed in building them they see no
reason why we should not succeed in
building them
right they need to be our friends in
some way yeah but if you teach the rocks
how to think you're not going to share
many purposes with them
how do you deal with a nested hierarchy
of eyes so for example someone says i
want to eat that chocolate but i don't
want to want to eat that chocolate
so it's like they have different eyes
different selves in your model
how does that work it happens in every
once of our minds we can see this
in children especially right so children
cannot establish behaviors
that integrate over long time spends and
i think the difference between these
different eyes is the time span the
length of the games over which they
integrate their rewards
so you have behaviors which integrate
over short time spends and those that
integrate over long time spans
and the difficulty is not so much to
find that integration and to implement
it the difficulty is mostly attention
deficit
sorry meaning if you are unable to
maintain
an intrinsic awareness on your long-term
goals
then you are in trouble if you are able
to model the world in deep time
uh that is the main difference between
powers between
power between individuals and groups is
whether you're able to
model the world deeply and act on
long-term plans so if we want
to have civilization prolonged then we
should identify with the highest eye
in the nested hierarchy we basically
should act on extremely long-term plans
right and we need to implement
incentives that allow us to
act on such long-term plans and i think
that for instance our present u.s
society
has forgotten this organization
so the idea was here to basically remove
structure
and as a result we have more freedom for
innovation
and at a certain level innovation is
indistinguishable from cheating
and the us is a society that basically
cheats a lot on all levels what do you
mean that innovation is synonymous with
cheating
it means that you play short games it
means that you try
to take shortcuts instead of doing the
right thing you do something that
creates a little bit more dirt here and
a sludge and toxic waste and you hope
you are able to deal with it later
well you can innovate and build wind
farms no
you can innovate productive technologies
so not all innovation is cheating
in that sense no of course not but uh in
some sense the
way in which you uh i comprehend our war
in society is to try to
move upwards by innovating and
a society that is well organized should
not be focused on moving everybody
upwards it's
about moving everybody inwards everybody
should get better at what they're doing
we want to have
in some sense the goal is not to make
bread cheaper
and more abundant because the bread is
already abundant you want to make it
better and more wholesome and more
healthy
instead we invent kinds of yeast that
make the bread go up faster
but that give a whole generation
problems with digesting it right so uh
having gluten intolerance is now a
widespread and ubiquitous phenomenon
despite
our civilization having been adapted to
uh
bread and yeast and wheat for a long
time it's because we changed the weeds
faster than we could adapt to them
and the way that we would adapt to them
would be by evolution which means
selection which means technically
all these kids with celiac disease and
the people with
mild gluten intolerance should have less
offspring and then after
a long time we have adapted to the new
kinds of yeast is this a price that we
are going to pay
for having the bread uh being a little
bit cheaper probably not right
and so by saying we allow bread like
this
or even bread we suspect that it works
like this this is cheating
or if you see for instance the current
increase
of uh disorders that are developmental
like
um sorry when you say cheating you mean
it's a net detriment to the society
it's basically where somebody knows that
what they're doing is wrong
if they take a long perspective if you
say
if you would believe in god would god
want you to do that
this is cheating if it is what uh what
god wouldn't want you to do
and what god wants you to do is to play
a very very long game is to do the right
thing
to the best of your knowledge and doing
a thing that
might work relatively well in the short
term but in the long term kills the bees
or increases the prevalence of autism
spectrum disorder
because you put stuff in their foot that
doesn't kill rats in three months but
disrupt their angular criminal signaling
during developmental periods
right this is what not what you should
be doing
and this doesn't mean that uh simple
blind activism is the answer activists
often know less about a subject uh
somebody who is um
has a neutral position a neutral
perspective on the thing activism is
distorting your perspective on things
and the people that have the most
distorted perspective
also tend to be the most activist about
it if you think about it right because
you are why is that who gets most
agitated about it
if you are extremely agitated about a
subject that is not important
you are going to be the activist if you
uh
the loudest voices that are the most
emotional yeah well if you or
the other way around if you are the most
emotional person you are you tend to be
the loudest one
i see yes yes and but of course it
doesn't mean that activism is per se
wrong
right uh it just means that uh this
certainty that the activist has about
things
is often not justified and it's
this is only basically a measured
message to my younger self
why what do you mean oh when i was 16
years old i needed
knew exactly what was in the best
interest of the working class
were you a marxist yeah of course i grew
up in the system and it made so much
sense and the crisis
you're an activist an activist yeah i
was basically
willing to be an activist about this and
when the war came down i was very much
in favor of not reunifying with western
germany but i wanted to have a model
that is more like uh
scandinavia and uh basically a third way
one that wouldn't be as all-out
capitalist and so on
i also thought this idea of keeping the
factories collectivist instead of having
them owned by billionaires
would be much more just and therefore
desirable right similar to how many
millennials see it right now which say
nobody should be a billionaire a
billionaire shouldn't
exist because it's so unjust but uh
and i thought when our working class
voluntarily decided to be exploited by
billionaires again which they did when
they voted for reunification
under the conditions that were on offer
i thought they were confused and being
manipulated by the press
and there was enough evidence that this
manipulation took place right there was
a lot of propaganda
for making that happen but what i was
too stupid to realize is
that this idea of justice only existed
in my own head
and what was real to people was under
which conditions do you send your kids
to school
what kind of food do you have on the
table what's the quality of your yogurt
how nice is your apartment what's the
quality of your carpet how many days of
holiday do
and that matters more than billionaires
owning a factory of course
it really matters it really matters what
the what are your living conditions and
you
if you have a society where elon musk
can unleash innovation
because he is a billionaire can control
resources in which that
a state-run committee or functionaries
of the party cannot
right uh this is the better society so
inequality is not
bad as long as the lowest tier has a
certain objective level of life
satisfaction
yeah i think it's very hard to justify
a society that uh where you have
equality
but everybody lives a shitty life it's
much easier to justify in a society in
which
the medium income is very high and
the poor people live a good life and uh
there is an extremely high inequality
inequality is not intrinsically bad the
question is
whether it's justifiable and or
the opposite whether the fight against
inequality is justified by creating a
world that is intrinsically better
and i think most people would agree that
a world in which the majority lives
better is the better world
right so this was the thing for i didn't
understand the systemic relationships
and i thought that differently you were
certain about it when you were
successful yes of course
because i didn't see the contradictions
yet i saw
a simple logical connection
that flew from the marxist theory that i
saw the antagonism between the ruling
class and the working class
i saw the injustice that would result
from the system i saw the limitations
that existed
within that system i saw the trend of
capitalism to destroy its environment
and itself
and to use more resources than it could
replace
and externalize the cost of production
to the environment and to
people that were not part of the markets
and so on but
i didn't understand that the
alternatives all attainable alternatives
were worse
and that the fact that our my own
society was worse was not the
result of lack of trying i thought it
was basically moral shortcomings of our
government
that led to the fact that socialism as
we experienced it had worse outcomes
than capitalism as
other people experienced it i didn't
understand that the capitalism that
existed in western germany
was a system that was constructed in a
better way than the socialism that
existed in the east
now the difficulty is the capitalism
that exists in western germany is also
not sustainable in the wrong and it's
also going to crash as far as we can see
in the us same thing same yeah same
thing
only worse because the system is larger
and the feedback loops are longer so
they're less
effective so it's better in the short
run uh if you have the system
we're playing the best level of the game
right now democracy works relatively
well in cities
and city-states and it's very difficult
to get it to work at the state level and
it's almost impossible to make it
effective
on a level of large nation state because
the feedback loops are too long right
it's very difficult to
set the incentives for governance rate
so do we need a global government
in some sense we need i think if we want
to regulate our relationship with the
environment properly
because otherwise we will have a
competition
about the things that we don't want to
compete about for instance
if we don't have a global government but
we have free trade we might have a
competition about who is willing to
allow uh the destruction of the
environment locally
more than others right well who is
willing to accept verse
conditions for their working class and
so if you had a global government you
would be able to regulate that
but if you on the other end have a
global government you don't have a
competition between different
governments anymore so
you have no incentive for the government
to govern well
how do you deal with that one and so as
a species
or as uh people that have political
theories we have not found universal
answers to these extremely difficult
questions
yoshi it's been extremely pleasurable
thank you so much it's probably the most
edifying and substantive podcast that i
have i don't know a subject that we
didn't touch on
menus thank you so much man
thank you too i enjoyed having this
conversation
by the way with respect to the social
justice movement
it's difficult i think to say in the
long term
whether it's a good thing or not it's
basically an ideological movement that
tries to become state religion and this
uh seems to be poised to do so and i
suspect
uh the reason why it is emerging it's
part is social media
right so social media is creating
incentives
for agricores to emerge and to possess
people
and the other thing is that the
mainstream society is not working very
well
and this leads to revolutionary
movements and
a part of social justice is about
redistribution of resources it's a
weird way of being a leftist in which
you don't care so much about
the economic conditions under which
people actually exist but you care about
the identities of people
so you don't care about the contrast
between
people living in chats and people living
in palaces but you
care about palestinian quotas for
your own people and so it seems to be a
movement that is largely driven
by uh the upper middle class
uh trying to get in the lower under
upper class
something like that right it's mostly
academics
that are already you could say in a
privileged position
uh and i'm putting this into square
skateboards because uh academia is uh
more open in a society that than it has
been for
most of the existence of humanity and
so in some sense the society is very
democratic in the sense that everybody
in the society is
free to become an oligarch and enter the
ruling class
and of course the society is not set up
in such a way that everybody can become
an oligarch it also would not work like
this and not everybody
is has the necessary traits to become an
oligarch
so the whole thing is in some sense
rigged but it's not rigged as it was
before where your birth decided
everything else and when you tried to
get away from what you were born into
people would go after you and kill you
and most of the previous social
movements for instance the
politics in cyrus russia were
working against the system of indentured
servitude or
the communists in france which started
the french revolution
were going against the monarchy which
was no longer
able to manage society in in the right
way right people were starving
despite an increase in productivity and
this mismanagement of society
had to be addressed and it was addressed
uh
in a way that was extremely brutal and
led
to by itself to starvation and to earn
the destruction of a lot of culture and
a lot of things that were
beautiful and probably deserve to be
maintained but the society it's itself
that was being destroyed was no more
sustainable
and that was the reason why this
evolutionary movement
propped up came up and then you have
violent revolutionary movements
that are destructive uh that it's this
is often
the result of uh your society not being
able to
implement mechanisms that perform
themselves in a more benevolent way
right in the us is stuck in this sense
it's stuck by
lots of mafias that take out resources
at every level
we're not able to build your
infrastructure anymore for that reason
for instance whenever we
try to build a new high-speed train the
money just evaporates
and when we try to hear cancer the
person
that has that concert typically goes
bankrupt in the process
so right something is wrong in that
whole system and
we don't have intrasystemic forces that
can repair the system
instead the system by virtue of its own
interest systemic forces
is getting worse so something needs to
change the system even if the
alternative
is worse for time being the alternative
eventually will need to get its [ __ ]
together after it's taken power
so i suspect that's that's what's
happening and so if we zoom out large
far enough it's very hard to evaluate
whether the present revolutionary
movements
despite the problems that they are going
to cause and already causing
are wrong all right
eventually it's we are just large groups
of chimpanzees that
tell each other stories about what we do